Oh,
[inaudible] is bad for your,
for your Wang,
for your Dick.
It's probably bad for a lot of things.
You know what else is bad for it?
For me at least personally,
my experience when I got off of it,
my endurance,
like really?
Yeah,
like I've felt stronger.
Like I felt like physically better.
I go,
we'll get tired like when I was on that.
Yeah,
I heard this terrible side effects.
Ari Shaffir experienced severe
depression from propecia and didn't put
the two and two together until after he
got off of it and a,
he had like bad depression and it was
all in.
He realized like,
Oh my God,
it all started when I started taking
propecia messes with your sex drive too.
You did.
[inaudible] guys.
My Dick,
like a bullet.
I'll be honest with you guys to take it
all the time and my Dick is always hard
hard right now.
You're amazing as you always like to
say.
It's not testosterone.
I'm just perfect.
He tells me,
I think might just ask her is too high.
Like look at your inbox.
You're built like this dude.
I took my shirt off.
Don't ever say you don't have any.
When I took my shirt off,
you went like this,
you go,
you held it in but you went like this.
You immediately might think I shuttered
and then you were like,
oh,
you need to get in better shape.
I was a woman that would be excited.
Yes.
Did have a pose off.
We had a post hoc just now two 48 year
old losers posing off.
Literally I'm on my phone,
Joe,
go shop.
We were making,
you were making you judge us,
making you jazz.
Are both my friends not be.
Both of you look great about who looks
younger.
At some point in time you're going to
grow up.
Like I always assumed that this would,
this would not be funny for me.
It wouldn't be with my friends.
Of course being retarded,
we loved it never ends 80 and doing
this.
I think so.
I think we'll always be attracted to
round soft surfaces.
Fighting's any kind of penetration and
it will get our attention always.
Like what happened?
He got punched him in the face.
Well listen to this crazy shit.
Dana White told me that the guy who
invented Regena King,
Peter Welling is that his name is in,
in Germany.
Dusseldorf.
Germany is the one that coby Bryant,
all those guys are flying out to Germany
to uh,
this regena keen procedure that
regenerate amazing antiinflammatory
properties.
He's figured out a way to regenerate
collagen with an injection with an
injection,
your body starts regenerating it's own
college and like a 20 year old Danny
saying wrinkles will just go away.
Your skin will just tighten up.
You are going to look like a much
younger person.
And this is all within like the next
year.
Really?
Yup.
There on that count.
He did look at my face.
You're beautiful.
So tight.
They're on the brink of doing this.
They're that close.
Like they're setting up the
infrastructure and they're getting rid
of the role with this stuff and when
they do that shit roll.
Hell yeah.
When they do,
it's going to be fucking bonkers,
man.
That's pretty wild.
You're going to see Barbara Walters
looking hot.
I know.
Whatever.
They're doing crazy stuff with tissue
regeneration.
I wonder when they're gonna be able to
do that to backs,
because people that have like really
fun,
like I ran into my friend alder was when
Eddie Bravo's black belts last night and
told me he hasn't been able to,
I haven't seen him awhile,
told me has it been able to do Jujitsu
in two years?
His back has been fucked up and it just
doesn't get better.
It's,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Well,
I'm doing a disc degeneration,
you know,
there are two girls I know who are in
wheelchairs,
you know,
and,
and uh,
they are,
are they going,
is it from Your Dick?
It's from a deck from the deck.
And,
uh,
you dictum they're both actually super
attractive.
I have to be honest.
And I,
I'd be lying if I said I didn't have,
so you're talking about spinal injuries
and you know,
obviously the,
the,
there's a long way to go before that,
but there's a guy in San Diego at doctor
who I guess works with electrical
pulses,
um,
and he has had some success in sort of,
he shoots and electrical sort of,
uh,
I don't know Paul [inaudible] in some
cases.
Uh,
it's,
it's given some feeling back on their
legs and stuff.
So it's,
it's promising,
but I think,
I think we're way now they're going to
fix all that stuff.
They just can't figure out how to
regenerate spinal tissue.
They can't figure out how to connect.
Once your cord is severed,
they can't do anything about it.
But they're very,
they're very hopeful.
I don't know what they're doing it with
penises.
I mean that you're unable to transplant
a penis.
Not only did the guy that they
transplanted his penis and he was
excited,
he got his girlfriend pregnant.
Wow.
That's right.
Yeah.
Craig was the hardest thing for so many
veterans is when they get their legs
blown off.
The first thing they talked to was
saying,
the first thing young men got to say is,
what's going on with my,
My,
my dad of course.
And of course,
and it's so devastating.
It's such a devastating wound.
And one of the things that they were
trying to get money for it and they were
like,
look,
we,
we legs are more important.
He said,
you have no idea what you're talking
about mentally for a young man when he
gets an injury to his groin,
that's fucking more devastating than
almost anything else.
Just to it down sizing.
Also,
when you,
Dick gets blown off with your balls like
you,
you don't have testosterone even
planning.
Exactly.
So it's obviously,
there's a lot a lot to say about that.
The horrors of war,
the idea that you can just figure out
how to fix bodies to the point where
anything that's broken can just get
repaired.
You know,
think about like 105 hundred years ago.
If you got a broken leg like 500 years
ago,
you're a dead man.
We're going to have to put you down.
The thing is,
you know the one thing,
they can't figure out how to help your
brain.
It's the only company kept figuring out
everything else.
You're good.
I feel like.
Why don't they just drill a hole and
shoot some stem cells on there?
I don't know,
man.
It's this crispr crispr cas nine is
fucking incredible.
That's the new frontier,
and in 10 years we're going to be,
we're going to be literally taking your
DNA and putting a gene in the area.
Apparently just shooting a gene in the
area of that.
When they snip your DNA,
there's this whole,
you know,
do you know how it works?
It's kind of wild.
This is a great radio lab podcast on
Chris.
I listened to it twice so I could figure
out what they were saying.
You know what?
The con is tall.
This though is the,
all this advancement and medical and all
that stuff and we're fixing everyone is,
it's going,
everything's gonna get over populated.
Right Pete,
when to stop dying.
There will always be plain old death.
I think the biggest question is how the
average lives can be way long.
It's already increasing.
Also,
how do you,
how do you pay for like there are
certain cancer treatments that are
$1,000 a pill.
I mean,
you can cure hep c now and it's $1,000 a
pill.
It'll cost you $84,000 but you'll cure
it.
You will for sure.
Take the cap.
C is is a curable disease.
It's not.
It's no longer a manageable disease.
Used to be really hard.
You'd have to take interferon,
which would only work on northern
Europeans buyer's club.
The look on Brennan shoves faces.
He can still fuck Pamela Anderson
with the bullet.
Hold on with the Collagen.
Sign me up son to it.
You've got to get her to do squats.
I know.
No one has little.
No.
I said no,
nothing.
Oh,
panhell.
I worked with her.
She hadn't asked easy.
When did you work with her?
I did stacked the great tv,
so in the 60s it may as well been stack.
She was,
she was 14 she was 38 and it's still
very hot.
How old is see at the time,
so you're talking about like at least 10
years ago?
About 10 years ago I saw Sydney
Crawford.
I was coming out of yoga in Santa
Monica.
She is jaw dropping.
Gorgeous.
Beautiful.
She had a long conversation with her and
her husband like six months ago at a
party.
Yeah.
She's,
she's loud as fuck.
Fucking,
she's like 50 yes,
51 something like that.
I love it.
She keeps it up baby.
She's in Christie Brinkley.
Yes.
62 have you seen it?
No,
it's hot as fuck.
Really?
She seems to have this older lady.
Oh No,
she was the hottest dog.
The lady I saw Raquel Welsh when she was
in her sixties and a straight up dime
piece,
but some women are beautiful.
They're whole fucking lake and hang in
there,
Barry,
rick and hang in there.
Fucking rare.
How much effort it must take to keep
that up.
I mean it's a day.
It's a job.
You don't think it's genetics.
It's probably that too,
but also effort.
I don't think there's any woman who
looks at that fantastic that doesn't do
something like either the fillers on
their face or they work out like a
fucking demon,
which is a mandatory or they go to,
they have to,
they have to probably do cryogenics like
that's Christie Brinkley.
She's 62 that's nuts.
My mom is very similar in age now.
I would go on a date with her too.
She's hot and that's not even a good
picture because like the sun's behind
her or faces in the shade.
Like she's legitimately high definition.
Beautiful.
That's crazy.
She might fall off it though when you
get in the sec.
You know what I'm saying?
Like bones of which probably just sleeps
all the time.
Just like the
bathtub.
It's filled with blood.
I started noticing,
I started noticing like for me like
about about four years ago,
maybe three years ago.
Like,
I noticed that girls just didn't look at
me the same when I come off stage like
I,
I mean I talk about my wife who's a,
but when when you as a young man like
you're doing standup,
you would always have some female
attention.
It's,
it's died down quite a bit.
Dry it up,
write up a little bit older.
I'm old guy,
I'm 48.
Now if a girl who is 20 and she would
just leave them there,
I'm sure like we were talking about it,
her friends would probably be like how
old is for sure.
Yeah.
Your fans know are more interested in
Bingo and shit.
I'm not very so what does that college
and Shit coming up soon?
I'm shooting national by the gallon,
but the couch catalog,
shoot it right into your face holes.
I'm going to take my shirt off here
cause I got cheap phone's off too.
Yeah.
But um,
they just don't like feeble old dudes,
you know,
weird like calling shoes and they don't
look like fuck gravity's winning.
Some guys,
some guys let themselves go.
I've never understood that.
Yeah.
Look,
we were just talking about Christie
Brinkley.
She's like way older than us.
Yeah,
but we would all fucker.
Yes.
Give him a chance and the right
circumstance.
I'm taking my sports to a new level.
By the time I'm 60 drugs playing tennis.
What does this tennis thing,
why are you so obsessed with that?
It's always been somebody.
You take them something manly.
Look at Jujitsu I box bro.
Oh yeah,
you do bro.
I go,
I go four rounds.
Amazing.
Don't why you're looking at his past and
as Chris van Heerden.
That's not the answer.
That's on the answer to that question.
It was about,
I don't have to get out of all the
details stuff going on.
Do you have about three?
It was about three weeks ago.
Did you watch the UFC this weekend?
I did.
Did you,
where would I and by the way,
yes,
not to brag,
but I called every single fight,
including the Rose Page fight and the
uh,
Frankie Edgar,
Edgar,
uh,
well you didn't call the result.
You didn't know.
He just picked those guys.
Pick the winners,
pick the winners.
I don't think anybody,
I thought Frankie had a real good shot
at decisioning.
Like when my friends ask me like who's
going to win?
This was going to win that.
I said Frankie has a real good shot of
decisioning chat.
The chat also has a good shot at
knocking Franklin percent.
The only reason I picked so fucking
hard,
I mean he knocked out Ricardo Lamas mean
he bangs and he also loads up.
Yes.
I just figured I,
for me I pick frankie because I,
I knew frankie wouldn't gas and I think
if anything,
I thought if Chad had to keep up with
Frankie's pace,
he would gas toward,
we'll chat actually came into this fight
light cause I think he anticipated that
kind of pace that frankie was going to
put on him.
So I was talking about two different
buckles and he said the chat was way
later for this fight.
He did a shit ton of cardio.
Like he was embarrassed by the conor
fight that he gassed out so quick.
Right.
Obviously took that fight on two weeks
notice,
which is a joke when you're a big guy
like him and you've got to cut weight to
get down to one 45,
his entire campus is probably all about
him losing weight,
you know.
But this,
this camp you got in real good shape.
I just got clip a lot of these fights or
it's a tossup,
like it's so close to the matches were
so close so he could have went either
way.
So many people were so fucking mad at
me.
We're after the fight,
they give suggestions like the UFC says,
um,
the truck will say,
who do you think should get the next
shot in your hair?
Yeah,
they say the golden goliaths.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
they had,
this,
the footage based up for Frankie Edgar.
And so I said,
um,
I said,
honestly,
I don't think that a rematch is the
right,
well,
you definitely could do a rematch.
The problem with doing a rematch is with
Aldo,
conor mcgregor and Aldo.
The problem with doing a rematch as it'd
be so hard to sell when a guy gets
knocked out that quick.
When you hype it up for as long as you
did,
you'll hype it up for two separate
events.
It dies off and then the first punch
connor connects with it,
puts him out.
He was a star,
but it's hard.
It's hard to sell that.
But if you want to look at like,
like lineage and you look,
look as history,
you'd say,
yeah,
Oh,
the guy was a champion for 10 years.
He should ever eat.
He wants to,
but does he sees it.
He's the thing.
There's a giant list of people.
People say that Cain got an immediate
rematch as a junior,
junior dos Santos knocked him out,
but he didn't.
He thought big foot Silva.
He knocked out big foot Silva and then
he got a rematch.
But traditionally,
traditionally inboxing,
correct me if you're not in box,
but that's the wrong argument.
You'll go off the UFC,
so here's the counter.
I can go,
I'm with you as soon as don't be,
we're like rematch.
I'm like,
well he just got murked in 13 seconds.
There's not much of a rematch.
But if you look at the history of the
UFC,
he should get a rematch just based off
the way they usually do things.
So we look at,
we look at Barao,
right,
we'll get brow,
he lost immediate rematch.
We look at Anderson Silva,
immediate rematch.
You know there's,
there's tons in the history.
Ronda rousey immediately match all
those.
Yes.
Such a bad ass.
He should get immediate rematch
according to what they've done before.
Right.
It make sense.
Not think what they've done before is
based.
I think a lot of it is based on like
what kind of compelling contenders do
they have for that title and especially
compelling contenders where you look at
their,
their style versus like the style of the
guy who is now the current champion and
if you wanted to pick like the most
intriguing stylistic matchup.
I think it's Frankie Edgar.
Yes.
Frankie Edgar.
Because I've fought at 55 and one the
title of 55 meet legends and Bj Penn
just knocked out Chad Mendez with one
punch before that.
Beat the fuck out of cub.
Swanson shut it out.
I mean he beat Uriah Faber.
He's,
he's fucking,
he's smushed everybody.
They put in front of them for a few
years now.
He's a monster.
He deserved.
But how can you give someone say like
Rhonda,
an immediate rematch and make holly
weight?
That's a very good question.
As you're saying.
I agree.
I'm not saying that Rhonda should get an
immediate rematch.
It's true.
You weren't,
but for the most part she's getting
immediate rematch,
right?
It's guaranteed.
Well that's the plan,
but she has to pass the medical to make
sure she's healthy and all that.
But the plan is she's going to get the
rematch,
but it's only financial.
But financially,
the Holly Holm fight with Ronda is the
biggest fight for Holly Holm.
Holly Holmes going to make like $7
million for the Ronda Rousey for her.
If I was Holly Holm,
she doesn't want to wait.
She wants to stay active.
And I totally understand that and I
think,
you know,
it should be her prerogative as a
champion to kind of choose,
but financially,
that's the smart fight for her.
Like it's good.
She's going to make the most money.
She does.
She wants to fight me.
Should tape before.
Yes,
she does.
Her and her camera.
Let's do Ameesha one's a fight.
The UFC saying no.
So how can you grow this law?
I'm saying you can't play favorites
because when the,
when the,
when the public smells favorites,
then you're losing credibility.
But does he have one tab for the
marriage?
Is that favorites or is that smart?
Financially was really good.
What about Verdomme cane?
That's comedian Kane and verdomme.
We're not going to have an immediate
rematch.
They offered for doom other fights and I
don't know how they came to the
conclusion of cane fighting,
but I apparently there was a bunch of
other people in the mix and they came to
settle on cane.
It might have been that it was her dooms
choice because financial reasons like
the f the cane fight will be much more
financially viable.
I get it,
man.
Hanan Barao you know what I'm saying to
you?
Give and morale.
He's not a draw at all.
Right Tj?
Whoops.
His asked you like left.
This guy's been a champ for so long.
We give him enough.
I see what you're saying.
That there should be consistency.
There has to be,
oh shit.
Hold on.
You don't know what you talking about
it.
You can't,
you can't play.
You know what I'm saying,
Joe?
Like you can't play favorites because
you're standing in line for a second.
The whole erupting him.
So,
but you,
there just has to be some sort of
consistent where you just can't play
favorites.
Well this is good here.
This is good here.
You know,
I keep the same with the,
and Damien Meyer brought the sub.
It's a great point.
Yeah,
it's the same with the,
the rankings because who the fuck where
the fuck you?
Here's one that doesn't make any sense
to me.
How come you Riaa hall knocked out Gay
Garden.
Who?
Saucy but gig massage.
He was ahead of him in the rankings,
knocked him out of his last visit.
A bunch like that.
There's a bunch like that.
That's a thing,
so that's the most egregious,
in my opinion.
There's been bigger ones that I've seen,
but most of the fighters,
we laugh at the rankings.
We used to laugh in the ring.
It's like one and two,
whatever it takes.
It doesn't take a rocket scientist to
figure out what to after that.
Who's voting on these?
I don't know about.
It's the same thing with a lot of these
title shots like,
okay,
let me ask you won't be taken seriously.
It can't be wwe style.
Let me ask you this.
Do you think there's an inherent problem
with the promotion being the UFC also
being the ones who dictate what,
what?
Who fights for title 100% because
normally it's not like,
what do you mean by that?
WBC like is a sanctioning body,
right?
For Boxing,
the WBC decides who's the mandatory
contender and then Bob Arum or don king
or golden boy.
Those are the ones who promote the
fight.
The UFC is both right there,
the sanctioning body,
and they're also the promoters of the
fight.
So they have a vested interest in going
with the best financial option.
This is why Tyson fury was just stripped
of his heavyweight title,
Tyson Fury,
just legitimately outbox Vladimir
Klitschko beat his ass just a hundred
percent.
It's kind of weird,
clunky style.
You have won every round,
every fucking beat Vladimir Klitschko
guys and lost in 10 fucking years.
And they had an immediate,
um,
uh,
defense of the title that they were
imposing on him.
And he passed on.
He said,
I'm not doing that.
They stripped him of his title.
This is within weeks of him beating
Vladimir Klitschko to the title.
So this is a drast,
drastic,
drastic contrast to what the UFC has.
The UFC would say,
look,
you,
I don't care what the ratings are,
you're fighting Vladimir Klitschko
again,
because that's where all the fucking
money.
Yes.
Right.
And that's what they would do.
Well,
think of the NFL and NBA did this,
or mlb,
if these other major leagues did this,
you'd have the most popular teams.
You'd have to say that he's in the
playoff lot of time you'd have,
it's not a valid comparison.
It is because not because you're talking
about,
no,
no.
Because you're talking about teams.
You're talking about teams versus
individuals.
It's not about Harrison,
don't you think disagrees?
I think you need to play for a
championship.
You have to go through a whole season.
You go through a whole season.
You have to win to even be in contention
to play for the super bowl to be in
contention to play for the major league,
but it's still not.
It's very black and white when you're
in,
but let me go see.
He's not black and white.
I may ask you guys a question about
about,
that's why it's not a valid comparison
because you can't sand junket taking
serious.
You're going to have to come up with a
formula where people can see the madness
behind your reasons.
I cannot tell her rhythm or something.
Right?
Yes.
That's what Demian Maia was saying.
Damien Maia was saying that after the,
the,
I think he said like,
I don't know how many victories in a row
he's had,
but at welterweight he's been virtually
like flawless.
I mean I think one person might have
beaten them at welter weight.
That's crazy.
Who beat Damien Maia at welterweight.
But look,
Damien Maia made a very good point.
Damien Maia.
So he's such a fucking respectful
gentlemen and such a,
a perfect representative of martial
arts.
That guy is a gym.
[inaudible] quote.
He goes,
I just do punching to set up my take
down so I can do Jujitsu cause I don't
want to hurt my opponent.
I want to be able to train the next day
because I just want to get in there and
win by Jujitsu so I can go back,
train.
They can go back to train.
Wow.
He's one of the good ones that he's
amazing.
He's the fucking young guy.
Destroy though,
hey,
let's quit tossing these young up and
comers and he just raped.
Oh,
but who cares?
I man each gun or just edit it and set
it up and let him choke them all.
Okay.
So Roy McDonald beat him.
That was the last guy at welter weight.
Oh.
And right before that was jake shields
beat him,
which was a great fucking fire man.
But that was a split decision.
Roy beat them unanimous decision.
Split decisions are so weird because
sometimes they are clear.
You just got an idiot judge and I don't
remember how about Romero and jock
array.
That was a very close fight.
I thought I was going to be a drawl or
split decision have been,
well I thought it could have been a draw
because I think eol definitely got a 10,
eight round the first round.
But the question is will they scored a
ten eight round when you got a guy
completely on Queer Street,
you spinning back fist him in the jaw,
knock him and John Corey was,
he got up to his,
uh,
after he took a fucking prolonged
beating on the ground,
he got,
he got hit with some bombs by Yo el.
He gets up to go to his corner and he is
on wobbly legs.
Like they could have easily stopped the
fight.
And I was thinking that they might
should have stopped that fight.
But jock,
right.
Being the stud that is came back and
reestablish himself in the second round.
Partially because Yo el gassed cause eol
who looks like a fucking superhero.
The most ridiculous history.
Not just for five,
three you mean three minutes.
Exactly.
That's why that's why he fights.
He fights luke rockhold and tries to go
five rounds.
This is my aunt Jo.
You can't give you,
I thought after that fight,
whoever wins,
you can't give those guys a title shot.
There's,
you do Weidman rockhold to you don't
give the winner of that bullshit fight
or a title shot.
I don't think,
uh,
I think you could make a real good point
to that.
Um,
but this sort of contradicts what you
said about having a very clear algorithm
as far as like who becomes a number one
contender and who fight too.
But this is the thing,
I'm going based off past UFC history.
You know what I think they should do.
I really think this,
I think there should be a way where
people sign in on facebook.
You know like you sign in using your
facebook so we know you're a real person
and the public votes.
Then you also have the media vote.
You have the mixed martial arts media,
like the the guys who was like the
Golden Globes almost.
Yeah,
something like that.
And then you have fighters vote.
So you have,
so just like how you have three judges
that score a fight,
you have three sources that you use to
pick who the contenders are.
It's a good idea.
Who the number one contender,
wisdom of crowds.
I think it's a bad idea and I think it's
going to lead to a lot of trouble if you
just leave it up to the UFC brass to
make.
I don't,
even though I work for the UFC and I've
worked for the UFC forever,
like people ask me questions.
I don't know.
Like when I get,
I don't know who the fuck does it.
I don't know who makes the rankings.
I don't know shit.
When I get to work,
this is what I do when I get to the UFC,
I say hi to everybody,
a hug,
everybody.
I get excited,
I go,
I can't believe this.
I start going over the,
the matchups.
I um,
I've already watched video on fucking
everybody in the card pretty much by
then.
And when I say I don't do research,
I'm kind of full of shit.
But it's not that I don't,
I don't do it as research.
I just do it because like,
oh,
it will be coming to him.
How's he fucking how to handle this
dude's got a nasty,
we re Alvarez kind of fucking wicked
good team.
Like if they go,
if he tries to take this kid to the
ground,
he's going to shoot for that double is
going to get caught.
Nikea teen,
it's not your job as is a fucking nasty
kickboxer he's gonna want to take this
guy down,
but it is my job sort of,
but I would have,
shouldn't know like the rankings and
decide that.
I'm just saying that I would,
I would do everything that I do even if
I wasn't working for the UFC just cause
I'm like freaking out about these events
and that's just what I get in the past.
But because again,
I don't know what the fuck is going on
besides that.
When I get there,
when I show up,
I say my highs,
I get my shit.
They put the mic on me,
I high five
Goldberg,
we hug each other.
Here we go.
You know what?
Don't they know?
I don't know what's going on.
Share more about your opinion and you
know,
especially in the public.
Well it's not,
some people are mad though.
This is what we got into the beginning
that I said I don't think that it's
smart to have all doe fight right away.
My opinion is that first of all,
although got knocked dead.
Okay.
When you get knocked dead like that and
you need a long time off,
you need at least six months off conor
mcgregor fight next Tuesday.
Yes.
And I think that Frankie Edgar could
also fight next to 100% I also think
that death fight will be fucking bananas
and for a Fan.
I am so excited to watch that fight
cause I think Frankie has a really
dangerous style for a guy like conor
who's taken it down repeatedly by Chad
Mendez.
True.
He's a fucking nasty wrestler.
His cardio is off the chain.
His footwork is fantastic.
He's got Mark Henry in his corner.
They're going to come up with a bad ass
game plan between Kenrey Henry and
cavenaugh and Frankie,
who's a fucking winner.
And Connor,
God Damn.
Let me ask you,
what would you be most excited about?
You ready for this?
Yes.
Cowboy to beat dos Anjos dos Anjos
Connor in Dublin in front 80,000 fans.
Oh yeah,
a hundred percent hundred percent you're
right.
Think about more writing.
You're right.
The title Donald Serone.
Connor,
let me just say one thing giant if,
yeah.
Hofeld dos Anjos is a fucking beast and
I think those two are going to clash and
who knows what's going to happen.
Especially since still sun just beat
cowboy.
The first fight.
I think it's going to be a wild wicked
fight drug that I'm no longer right.
Oh,
drug testing.
Did you just say there's going to be
that crf but wait,
wait,
take me back to a second.
Let me say one thing about you've got to
give Josie Aldo a rematch in my opinion
for two reasons.
One,
I think that at the end of the day he
was the champion for 10 years and if
anybody's earned a shot too.
I know I believe.
I think conor mcgregor is has a secret
which is he's,
he's watching these guys strike and know
something.
They don't know he's,
he somehow,
I don't know if he sending to doesn't
matter.
Hold on Hon because that's just saying
who you think is going to,
what I'm saying is this,
when you knock a champion who's been
that dominant and that good for 10 years
out in 14 seconds there is the question.
There is a question which is was that in
some ways a fluke,
what did he make one mistake and paid
for it,
which can happen in mma with those small
gloves,
does he get another shot to at least
kind call longer how it goes.
He's going to come out extremely
aggressive.
I'm going to count and I know that and I
hold it and you see the video of him
warming up in the dressing room and then
in contrast like a split screen with him
warming up right next to the actual
fight itself.
He was preparing exactly for that
maneuver and he's making,
he's mimicking all those face first
movement and he does this little slight
step to his right hand side.
He makes
an adjustment.
He throws the first left hand,
the first land hat and debt doesn't
land.
So if you watch him,
him moving,
he throws that sidekick to the leg.
Then he makes a very slight step to the
right although moves to the right hand
counters them with the left boom.
Hey know something.
That's what I'm saying,
cause I think that he would fight him
again and knock them out of that's real.
I think it's irrelevant.
Champion gets a rematch.
I think he deserves it.
I really do.
But here's the thing,
it ties up the title for a long time and
you have all these contenders.
Yeah.
You have an amazing group listed
contenders.
How about this?
How about you have Joe's a Aldo fight,
Max Holloway and you have a fucking
great fight between one of the top
contenders and Max Holloway.
This young,
exciting kid,
24 years old,
Pete and everybody just figure it out.
Jeremy Stevens,
he's elusive.
He slick.
He puts on a fucking show where a
motherfucker,
he has crazy cardio.
He's driven and fired up and you can't
quite have them fight for the title yet
because Frankie's ahead of him and it's,
you know,
the division is super exciting.
Frankie fucking clear.
The way man fight.
Frankie was pissed.
He didn't get the shot when Chad got it.
After he beat Uriah,
he,
they thought that Frankie,
his safety first style gets Uriah was
boring.
You want a decision?
He didn't try to finish him.
Chad went out and blew ricardo lamas out
of the water.
Chad gets to shun Frankie's like,
what the fuck?
But I did the cub Swanson.
Look what I did do all these other
people.
So then what does he do?
He goes out there and takes it out on
chat.
Merck,
something.
Put some away in my opinion,
like as a fan,
I'm excited to see that.
I think here's another thing.
I really believe this wholeheartedly and
I think this is a very important point.
Fighters should wait a long fucking time
after they get knocked out like that.
True.
He got cleaned,
he got flat,
and then he got hammer fist.
As he was out,
he,
he got up and he was asking what
happened,
what he was putting his hands up and
going,
I don't know what he's saying because
he's speaking in Portuguese.
Because he was shaking his head and they
were nodding their head.
They were saying yes and that would be
goes,
no,
no.
And they were going,
yes,
yes.
Here's the other thing Joe.
A lot of people are talking about,
I hate to be a stickler and I took some
fucking shit for saying this.
You're bat shit crazy if you don't think
Josie Aldos body looked different.
You're batshit crazy.
If you think he's going to fight the
same also and all these people are
giving me all the shit for it.
His Camp I think is one in seven Oh and
eight since this drug test and came out.
So you're talking about a different
fighter man,
a completely different fighter.
Well,
so for me that's a huge x factor.
There was a leaked audio from inside the
truck of me saying that someone got the,
when the,
when the audio goes out,
there's an audio feed when the main
event happens and when that main event
audio feed goes out,
they,
anybody could listen to it.
That is it picking up the feed to it and
broadcast.
And I said that his body looked
deflated,
it looks smooth and that,
um,
I felt like he looked really nervous.
I said he looked nervous as fuck and I
said,
I don't want to jump to conclusions.
He might just be doing a lot of cardio,
which is possible because one of all
those big problems,
and Dana White,
he said this is a perfect way of
describing it,
that all of those,
the very best fighter ever for two
rounds.
And then he would always gas and then he
would always sorta coast like Ricardo
Lamas.
He'd beat the shit out.
Alarmists the first round,
the end of the fifth round,
Ricardo Lamas was on top grounding
pounding dominic to mark comics.
Same Goddamn thing.
Well,
he was on the antibiotics with harmonic,
but yeah,
for staff.
I think so.
That was,
I never heard that he was,
when he fought harmonic,
he had just done,
he'd had staff need done.
Google that,
Jane.
That's true.
Um,
but,
well,
how about Luke rockhold won the fucking
title unbelieved on,
on antibiotics.
Did any protocols when his first match
and Ebi yesterday,
um,
he had,
who's dying of staff days in the
hospital.
It's their mother and he was in the
hospital for a week.
Like denny was dying on stat from staff
just to come to you surprised by the,
by Luke's domination.
Like that.
Totally surprised.
Totally surprised by a lot of thing and
we totally should get to that.
But um,
I,
I don't know if Aldo had concentrated
more on cardio or if he had gotten off
steroids,
but I do know,
and this is nonspecific,
there's a huge problem in mma with
steroids is a huge problem and that
problem is being cut away like cancer by
this new program by Jeff Novitsky.
I also know that they tried to test all
don't camp and all those people had the
cops pulled on these people.
They wanted to get him kicked out of the
country.
They were trying to de de de,
de port them out of the country.
Then when they finally did give him a
urine sample,
he tripped and spilled his pice.
Is this not weird to anyone?
That's insane.
Doesn't take them a true way.
Spilled piss in my entire career.
I have.
The thing is his cups all the time.
It does get feathery.
All there was covering from an
undisclosed infection.
It was on antibiotic hall.
Callan,
hey guys,
come on guys.
The thing is I should know that it
doesn't take away anything that all was
done in his career.
Even if he is,
I'm not saying he's never failed a test.
So who knows.
Right.
We needed Lance Armstrong.
There you go.
All insane is all I'm saying is it
seemed with Lance Armstrong steam was
baseball.
He was exonerated.
He stolen the pitch on some shit.
Yeah,
everyone's on some shit.
Alright,
great.
No matter whether he's honored or not,
he's greatness.
This I'll,
Josie Aldo is one of the greatest pound
for pound fighters ever.
For sure.
Ever,
ever.
And to go on a 10 year run like that,
you don't in the UFC has said like,
hey,
you know he'd played it safe and he goes
to decisions.
You shouldn't do that.
But you know what else?
He's great.
But here's the thing,
he fucking wins.
Yes.
And like him risking losing,
like to unload on somebody like Uriah
Faber did.
Like uriah faber flat,
Frankie signs and your riots sort of
faded in that fight.
But the reason why faded is cause he
landed a bomb on frankie signs,
rocked them.
And then when after I'm blue as load,
that fucking frankie signs guy,
he's tough as shit cause that this is
the 35 year old guy who's got like one
other fight in the UFC.
Maybe two.
Okay.
And then he's fighting Uriah
motherfucking favor.
Right.
Okay.
Was this crazy?
It was ranked 13 yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it's your why of Faber is like
one of the most experienced guys and one
of the best guys ever did not win a UFC
title.
Right?
He's only lost title fight.
Yeah.
So he,
he bombs on this guy and then nails him
with a knee to the,
I think it was a temple tart.
Some parts,
some bad.
I mean the kids all over the place and
your rise unloading on him and that
somehow the guy survives and then your
eyes like he's like,
oh boy.
You know,
he's like,
she's took a deep breath and kind of
looked at the clock is like you know
better than anybody that when you unload
like that,
that's never how anybody fights.
So when you unload like that,
you're going all in,
you're pushing all your chips and this
guy just pulls out four aces.
You're like,
boom,
bitch,
Connie,
what happens?
That's when you got to use carbon.
No,
perfect one sample palm strike.
You guys never use plumbing skit from
the huddle.
How about your eye goes,
our friendships done.
Tj dillashaw,
your Ryan White.
He was saying,
he was saying it's going to be like
rocky and the good guys.
Gonna wait,
wait.
Why?
What happened?
Him and Tj,
they had a falling out because tj went
to muscle farm.
The muscle farm offered him,
but I don't follow the will.
The reason,
one of the reasons why Tj went to muscle
farm is two reasons.
One money,
but to Duane Ludwig.
Yeah.
Duane Ludwig and Tj have a fantastic
working relationship.
Duane Ludwig is a fucking,
he's got some crazy mental disorder that
makes him concentrate on fighting every
single second of every day.
I think he's got a running thing.
I think he could be hanging out with his
wife,
going to the movies,
eating dinner,
talking about baseball in the back of
his head.
He's watching counter,
right hands,
leg kicks,
movement session.
He looks the rain man of fighting.
He's obsessed,
man.
He's obsessed.
And that's exactly what you want from a
trainer.
Tj recognizes that and his personality
and Dwayne's personality jive.
Whereas your bias personality and
Dwayne's personality,
we're water and oil.
They fucking clashed hardcore and you're
Ryan never wanted to have anything to do
with that guy.
He's like,
fuck this guy.
And dwayne and him didn't get along and
Dwayne was like,
fuck him.
And they argued about stupid shit and
you know,
here's something that a lot of people
don't know.
There was a point in time where we were
considering buying that Jim on it and I
was going to be on it.
Yeah,
we're gonna,
we're gonna buy the ultimate training
center.
We were thinking about buying it and
making that team like an audit team and
we were talking to those guys about how
to make this work,
but it was right when they were starting
to go at it.
When dwayne and Uriah,
we're trying to go at it and we were
like,
first of all,
it was the like,
I was going to have to figure out like
how,
how would I do this and be impartial.
It's very difficult to do.
You know,
you're like,
I love cowboy serone I fucking love that
guy.
He's awesome.
I'm I hanging out with them when I'm in
Denver.
He's the best,
the best.
It's just amazing personality.
He's just,
I just want to hug them when I see you
want to be around the couch and he's
just a true bad ass too.
And I respect,
I deeply respect Hoffeld dosantos I
think he's a great fighter and he's a
great guy.
I went to our,
he,
he's very friendly and,
uh,
you know,
I was,
um,
who,
who was telling me that,
uh,
there were,
um,
oh the fuck was it?
God dammit,
I'm drawing a blank.
Someone was telling me that they,
they were,
um,
hanging out with him somewhere and he
was like helping them out and telling
them where the best places top deal with
me in Brazil.
That's right.
Thank Jesus Christ.
Oh my God,
I feel like the nicest guy ever.
He's going to do,
you'll see now with them every now and
then.
He's a great guy,
but so I have to be completely
impartial.
You know,
I have to,
I have to figure out how to separate
myself.
But is it even,
can you even ask,
can I ask myself to do that?
If I owned a gym and I had fighters who
were fighting against guys who are a
team that you own basically.
And you know what I mean?
I don't know man.
Everybody always thinks that they're
always gonna feel.
People are always gonna feel like you're
biased in some way or another.
If they find,
if they,
if you're rooting for,
if they're rooting for someone and
you're calling the fight against that
person,
that they're rooting for it,
they're going to consider it.
It some sort of,
I've never seen,
I've never heard you be biased.
I'm todd [inaudible].
You are like,
fuck that Russia shit.
Damn dumb ass down.
No one's ever been harder than you.
It's the hardest,
hardest fights ever to call.
Cause like,
you know,
I can do it when you lost a travis,
like I was
broken up man.
It was hard.
Turns to me he's had at least he didn't
get hurt.
That's the important thing.
It was hard.
That was hard.
Kallan was right behind me.
He was sitting right behind me.
That was a hard [inaudible] he came in
here like close.
Yeah.
Well it was close.
It was super close fight.
But again,
you know it's,
it's a tricky but so this is all we were
just talking about Duane and Uriah like
they just didn't get along,
which is totes.
It's so,
it's such a fucking bummer because if
their personalities did like,
I almost felt like man,
if there's a middleman here that comes
in and sorts all this debt,
like what did,
I felt like what is the issue?
Is this a financial thing?
Personality things,
two Alphas personalities,
guys,
guys who get territorial,
guys who want your [inaudible] really
strong personality and he's also like
super organized and successful.
Super successful and super focused.
Like your Riaa is like,
you know,
he's a very admirable person.
Like when you watch like how he conducts
business and also look at the tight knit
bond that he's created with his team.
Yeah.
You know,
you only create that kind of a bond when
you are that kind of a leader,
you know,
and that's what he is.
And so for him,
when Tj took off and went to this muscle
farm camp,
I'm sure that it was like a knife in his
back.
Fucking devastating.
Well Tj and your I should fight no
matter what happens with Tj Dominick
Cruz,
that fight has to happen.
I really think so.
I'm so excited about teachers'
excitement of this.
The back story.
We love a good story.
You know what I'm saying?
It'd be so don't we do that dominick
Cruz,
tj fight might be one of the greatest
fights.
Dominic Dominic would have dominic wins
and then Uriah and Tj fight for a number
one contender status.
But your eye in dominic have a history
too.
That's not a bad story either.
It's not a bad story.
Can you,
can you think of another more compelling
contender that would be ahead of your
Riaa besides Tj?
Like,
say if Dominic Beats Tj or,
well,
whoever wins that fight,
who would be next in line for the title
instead of Uriah.
Who else?
10 and brow
isn't it?
He'll make the argument,
he could make the argument but he's have
to win again.
He got destroyed and his last fight,
Tj didn't destroyed teenagers,
didn't just beat him.
He lit him up like a Christmas tree,
covered them with gasoline and lit them
on fire and drug testing and through him
threw him off a cliff.
I mean it was,
no,
there was not a moment in that fight
other than the first initial exchanges
where he was like fired up and it's like
bully beach,
Tj and dominick Cruz have such similar
styles.
I almost feel like,
like dwayne watched a lot of dominick
Cruz fights and kind of,
I mean as,
am I wrong about that?
Well there's a lot of guys that are
employing that sort of neo footwork
movement now,
but I think dominick was the best at it,
the earliest he's,
he's so elusive.
It's like,
so like,
like you get used to a guy like here's a
different weight class but is a
quintessential like Thai style.
The style striker,
like thiago Silva stands right in front
of you and he's got that fucking rhythm
and he's,
you know,
he's not,
not mobile.
And then you got the complete polar
opposite,
which is like connor.
Connor is like,
like when you see conor fighting Aldo,
he slide Nin he slide now.
Like he's very difficult to judge,
in my opinion,
the best ever at that is dominic
dominic's all over the place.
Like he's fucking move in a sliding.
He's over here,
he's over there and you're trying to
figure out when you can uncork a punch,
like a good luck time.
And that guy,
have you ever had a conversation with
dominic?
Very,
very smart guy.
Have the highest MMA Iq I've ever seen.
Wow.
I agree with you.
I'm saying it was my favorite out of
those guys that breaks down fights and
analyzes what went wrong,
why it went wrong and he's a real
student.
Uh,
one time,
uh,
dominic and chill.
Sonya and myself went to unbreakable gym
and we were trading with jails before
Charles fight and Jon Jones and we
training jail and dominic was breaking
things down.
I was like,
Holy Fuck,
God gets an oracle can also,
he's had all this time,
he's had all his time while he's been
injured to think and work on things and
he's not,
it's not like you stopped paying
attention to mma I keys,
he's been focusing on it.
Whereas,
you know,
if he hadn't been injured,
he'd be in camps.
Getting ready for fights,
like almost might've benefited his MMA
Iq to have that time off and to be
obsessed with returning about what he's
gonna have his hands full kcls.
And you've had that surgery.
Can you get,
when you get acl surgery nowadays,
is it,
is your knee as strong?
Because I'm strong,
it's stronger,
stronger,
quite a bit stronger.
My,
my right knee has a cadaver graft.
It had a cadaver graft.
And what the cadaver graft does is they
take an Achilles tendon,
which is way thicker than a regular acl,
and then they put it in place and then
your body re proliferates.
That acts as a scaffolding and you're
not stem cells.
Your body grows like they restat,
they connect it and your body starts
putting blood through it and then
growing new tissue.
Wow.
So your,
your acl becomes your own.
Like I had a,
I had a cadaver graft,
but those cells are not cadaver cells
that are in my,
near south.
Those are myself,
but it's way thicker than it would have
been.
But Donald 150% stronger than
[inaudible].
So,
so that,
that's the case maybe with Dominic's
knees,
he tore the same one twice and then
toward the other one he taught tour one
twice toward the other one and he tore
his groin and he broke both his hands.
He's,
he's,
he's a fragile God.
Like when I had him on,
I'm one of those UFC interview shows.
He was joking around.
I mean,
show me scars in his hands.
He's got,
I got a bitch hands.
It's just,
it is what it was like.
This Guy Greg Cook,
this Guy Greg Cook who has full bar,
like the NFL now has what's called a
full body screening or some functional
body screening.
The UFC has got that now too with their
new camp because they were finding they
would bring him in and he would find
that that is all amazing athletes.
And then one guy kept tearing,
he'd run and he kept tearing his groin.
He kept telling the tenant had attached
his like to his pelvis to his quad and
it couldn't figure it out.
And he's the guy who comes in and goes,
I know what the problem is.
You're off balance.
One side of your body is stronger than
the other and that's a huge issue.
It's really common.
Yeah.
So now the training centers around,
you know,
basically finding out where you're weak
and you know,
you very common around that with
pictures cause you know you throw in
with one arm.
Yeah.
And kickers like nfl kickers,
they have real problems with that.
Like back problems because you're always
kicking that one leg in the same way.
For Dominic though.
It's years of wrestling and he's a
champion for ever.
He's only had one loss.
He's up.
It adds up.
You can chalk it up to inbounds.
Nomad is Uriah.
Uriah caught him with a good team so me.
Well you're right,
it gets your neck.
You know,
he fucking giant people often get done
the cruise beat,
Demetrius Johnson,
he beat Dj dam but they also forget that
was one day they didn't live anywhere
near Matt Hume.
He was coming into town once a week.
This is a fact.
He wasn't training like the,
the Ian Mccall fight was the big
turnaround for Dj.
And I had him on the podcast.
He talked about it cause he,
you know,
Ian fucking rattled his cage and it hurt
him.
He had vertigo after that fight.
It was pretty fucked up and I'm mad
human pulled him aside and said,
look,
you've got to stop fucking around.
Like we're going to do this.
Or you should maybe get an education.
Like you should figure out what the fuck
you going to do with your life,
but this ain't it.
Like you've got to figure it out.
And so he went all in,
moved near the the gym and now he's here
five days a week and look at him now.
He's,
I'm just saying dumb dum ba dum
different one though.
And different weight classes.
Just shots.
Some different guy now do dimitris at
tiny guy.
He's much smaller than not.
When it calms tiny too.
He is thin,
but he's taller and longer and bigger
and like one 35 is a cut for him.
Demetrius Johnson is to put a rock in
his pocket to make one 35 wow.
They got different fighters.
Completely different.
Totally different fighters.
They're much better now,
but just seeing them on both of them are
better now.
I'm fucking so excited for that fight.
I'm going to be there.
It's in January.
Boston.
Yep.
Tj motherfucker.
Are You doing the Florida court tomorrow
or next week,
right?
Yeah.
This weekend,
Friday,
Saturday,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
That's a good barn.
That's a good card.
Really good cuts.
Our lawsky versus a,
I mean not our Lasky Junior dos Santos
vs.
Alistair overeem was on that car to,
Ooh Johnson.
Michael Johnson versus Nate Diaz.
Juries.
On the flight.
Go to my church.
I was miles jury down to one 45 now.
Yeah.
Hafez dos Anjos and the size of those
not just head.
Look at that head.
Yeah,
my Lord.
Jury.
Yeah.
There's Jerry Olivia the fucking fight.
CB doorway.
Oh my God.
I don't even know.
That was the only card.
Hey,
nate said it.
What do you want to tell him?
Stop.
I love them.
It's been rough watching him.
The last few fights.
Do you think CBA,
CBA just chases after him,
puts it to him.
He kind of got it right.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
They'll tell you,
beat nate,
get on his back foot and throw bombs.
He just seems like he's absorbed so much
punishment after the law over the last
few years.
Bomber man.
It is Obama and he's been on it.
He was on the street until he got dealt
with.
Yeah,
I mean cb the Oto beat him.
I heard him at that body kick bad and
uh,
who else beat him?
The Doberman Nodo really fucked him up.
That was,
that's what ended his streak.
That left kick,
ma'am,
that left kick of Leah's cards and super
interesting man.
Dos Santos over him.
I don't know what to tell you again.
Testing's going to be a mother fucker.
I said what you think a hundred percent
yeah.
Fight should have happened three years
ago when it was all fucking the wild,
wild west.
I don't think.
I thought they didn't.
They fight the fuck.
Is this the person they're fighting?
No.
Brian,
this is the first time they're not.
He know so much about mark harmonic
versus Josie.
Hey,
I'm making a call.
I'll tell you something else.
I'll tell you something else I'd like to
see.
You're going to,
the guys are gonna Laugh at me.
I like to see something I'd like to see.
Don't say boyfriend.
I'm going to say don't say something
stupid.
I'd like to see my boyfriend and he is
my boyfriend,
Luke rockhold and my best friend,
cause I've had dinner with them and hung
out with him.
Uh,
I'd like to see him fight Jon Jones.
I said it,
but he,
he's just won the middleweight tiny.
I know what he won,
Bro.
You,
can you ask him to leave?
Hey John.
John is fantasy shit that you have in
your head?
Yeah,
it is fantasy shits a stand on my head
cause it's turning.
It's,
you know when you see a Weidman versus
rockhold and then Weidman wanted to
fight Jon Jones for the light
heavyweight title.
Yeah.
Weidman's movement wasn't the same.
I weidman looked off to loss a lot of
weight.
He was a in the one nineties in Hawaii
biblically on me like that.
I don't think so.
It was a strategy where he said,
I'm going to,
maybe he's on steroids.
Look,
but that's just not the guy.
I think what I'm saying,
I come in there,
I'm going to be light.
I'm going to hit them with pace,
uh,
cardio pace.
I'm going to wear him down.
He did.
I think he did do that.
I think that was,
I mean he was throwing a lot of like,
not full power kicks to the body,
but a lot of,
a lot of pressure,
a lot of pressure with his grappling.
He just fucked up throwing that we'll
kick stay in your lane.
Oh my God.
Fuck you dude.
I was one of the biggest mistakes in the
history of mma championship fights.
100% talking about it like,
it's not like a mistake.
Like,
you know,
you go through like throw a or leg kick
and you get countered with the right
hand and get hurt.
That's normal stuff.
This is a crazy acrobatic move
that he's telling beach bar.
Yeah,
he probably was right because that's
what knocked out rockhold maybe thought
he's a sucker for wheel kicks.
The grind is working for you when he's
taking him down and starting to work.
Starting to weird lookout.
Especially like we knew luke was on
antibiotics.
Fuck yeah,
keep doing that.
But he didn't think he knew.
He knew that Luke's pace was slowing
down.
Right.
You could tell.
I think what happened was he realized
that he was a lot stronger than Chris
Weidman.
He's,
he looked just stronger,
bigger,
and I think he went,
and you know what?
I wrestled with Cain Velasquez and,
and uh,
Daniel Cormier,
I'm stronger and bigger than this guy.
And that's what happened.
I think he just started.
No,
there's something that happened at all.
He caught him,
he made a mistake and he took him down
the keys through a wheel kick and
literally gave his fucking body up.
You get taken down and when rockhold
gets you on the ground,
his fucking top games.
Nasty,
super nasty.
And you saw it against Leo Machida.
Like I would like to see rockhold in
just straight up Brazilian jujitsu
competition.
I bet he is at a very high level mother
fucker.
I just think that that's why I'd like to
see a rematch.
You say that kick doesn't happen.
We've got a hell of a firefighter.
That's a hell of a fight anyway.
Cause that back kick that happened in
the third round.
I mean this is a fourth round stop it
and I had at one to one.
Yeah,
I did wonder one.
It was a really good fight.
It's not like,
you know,
Weidman came out guns blazing face first
and rockhold connected with straight
left with like conor and Aldo.
This is like a war.
And then at the end of the war,
you know,
I mean rockhold got that advantage.
Never let it go.
Adding Weidman in the face more.
I feel like he was,
I feel as though he was kind of standing
on the edge of that pocket and he was,
he has hands down and I,
I felt like rockhold seems so confident.
Maybe it was gas,
but he looked,
he was just confident enough to just,
he knew where the shots were coming in
and they would counter,
he was hitting him in the face.
More Weidman was pressuring him and his
kingdom,
his body,
it put more pressure on him.
Really paying off to the body is thrown
a lot of body.
So we're Luke's though.
In the beginning of the fight,
they were hard.
You're going to have to,
he who you didn't like laying to any
flushing and cottey kicks hard.
God exert her cane side.
What does that look like?
It must be just one of the hardest
kickers in the division for sure.
Rock holds long.
And you know what's interesting when I
talked to Javier Mendez,
I said,
did he have a traditional martial arts
background?
He goes,
nope.
He came to me when he was 17 and I'm
like,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Because when you watch like the
flexibility and dexterity,
like the looseness of his legs,
like when he throws that question mark
kick off the front leg,
he's so fucking Lou serone style.
Yeah.
It's like,
like ceremonies had more time for
fucking years and you look at Rocco's
genetics,
his dad was a professional basketball
player.
His brother's a professional surfer.
Have this monster just looming.
Wayne,
do you find something?
He found his calling him and me at 17
what we get,
I think what we're starting to see is
we're getting guys who are martial
artists,
but they're really good athletes and
that's who's taking over Holly Holm.
Jon Jones,
freak athlete.
John Jones [inaudible] think you're
totally right.
Rockhold freak athlete.
I think you're totally right.
I think,
um,
but it's just so shocking to me out of
all those that I see.
Well,
holly obviously has a long extensive
kickboxing background under winkeljohn
has a fantastic trainer,
but the thing that freaks me out the
most about rockhold is the,
the,
the flexibility and dexterity of his
legs that takes so long to develop that
kind of whip.
You know,
like his kicks aren't just hard.
Like Weidman has strong kicks,
there's strong like he throws him,
but there's a stiffness to him that
rockwell doesn't have.
Rock holds got like a taekwondo thing
going on.
Big,
big fucks up.
He's a fucking business.
He was just 16 and and San Jose when we
were hanging out,
I said,
how much do you weigh?
He was like,
sure was 16 of course I did.
I took them down and in your face I took
him in and I took him in.
But don't kid yourself.
Had My hand on his back couple times.
Talk this track.
Brian came back from hanging out with
Lewis,
had got his haircut just like him.
I went,
the fuck you doing?
He goes,
sounds around luke.
So I wanted to get my hair cut like
you're 48 copy.
And I look him in the eye and I went
exactly like loop when we go to a bar.
And I looked at my one that is and we
caught eyes and I looked at him,
I went,
I tell Ya.
And he goes,
he smiling.
He went six three and I go,
of course you are.
And I looked at his hair and I go,
I don't want to take you to go deeper
with your voice.
We had a moment,
guys.
We had a moment here that I went right
to super cuts for $12 and I go,
oh my God.
And I looked through the camera picture
of Luke rockhold that you fucking piss
my and fingers.
My friend Tarik who trains luke goes,
hey,
counts here.
I think you'd would suck luke stick.
We asked them did
you can take I think out of that
sentence.
All right,
I'll do it just as a goof.
Don't tell anybody.
What a shocking moment.
What is shocking turn of event that one
wheel kick changes the entire fight.
She see Chris crying.
Yeah.
It was also the,
the pressure that rockhold put on him,
I think surprised Weidman,
like when rockhold mounted him and for
sure not gonna eat those on.
I would never eat those when brock hold
mounted him
and,
and he couldn't get them off of him.
I think he was fucking shocked,
especially when,
you know,
lyman has really good Jitsu and when he
felt rock holds pressure,
it's first time he's ever been taken
down.
First Time it's backspin on the mat and
he's like,
no,
he's strong.
He's stronger than,
he had a technique to stronger t his
technique was superior.
It was amazing to see.
Yeah,
it was amazing to see.
He's a fucking beast and I think
there's,
you can't underestimate the benefit of
training with Daniel Cormay and Cain
Velasquez,
the heavyweight,
the former heavyweight champion and the
light heavyweight champion.
They're going to ask her if there's a
chance they could have the heavyweight
champ light heavyweight champ,
and now middleweight champ.
All training together all came up
together.
How crazy is that?
It is a possibility,
but the light heavyweight,
you got to put a little asterisk next to
it.
I'm just saying right now,
son.
I'm just saying right now you gotta pull
astro,
big astrid analytic.
Especially now.
Now that John's trite,
I thought left and 600 pounds,
Graham and I watch him.
I watch him throw my phone away,
run out the door.
I don't want to be around.
It's crazy.
John's a monster right now.
He's,
he's also a monster that's overcoming a
really bad moment in his life and he's
on the straight and now,
now he's on the path.
That's care while he should be.
And those are good things to happen to
you.
You know,
sometimes,
you know I've said this before,
but I'll say it again.
I love a comeback story.
I fucking,
I like a guy who,
who does the right thing and gets it all
together and I love that.
But I also like a guy who fucks his life
up and brings it all together and love
those stories though.
Like I,
I don't think John should be someone who
is not,
you know what I'm saying?
Like do all this stuff is great,
but be the heel man,
be the fucking joker,
the UFC and fucks to destroy.
He wants to be Jon Jones.
I don't think John Thinks of himself as
a bad guy and I don't think he is a bad
guy.
I think he's a young guy who's trying to
have fun and he's made some mistakes.
That's what I think.
I don't think he's a bad person to
person.
I don't think he's a bad person.
I think he's a far cry from Holly Holm.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's a holiday for me.
Home is the perfect represent.
I talked to her after the fight.
Nice person of all time after the,
oh she might be easily,
I talked to her after the fight this
weekend and you know we were talking,
hanging out her and her husband,
which I just said congratulations.
How's it feel?
She's like,
it does.
It still feels weird.
It doesn't feel real.
I'm doing so many.
She goes,
but I don't even want to think about it.
I just want to get back to training
cause I don't want to get a big head and
you know,
and she's,
she knows the traps and we were talking
about the fight and she was,
you know what I'm saying?
She said,
look,
the reality is what happened tonight to
Josie,
all that could have happened to me.
It can happen to anybody and she goes,
you get caught with a punch and you get
knocked out.
It's happened.
She's been in the sport too long I think
to get a big head.
I think she realizes the traps and she's
been fighting for world champions before
so she doesn't want to fall in that same
kind of Rut that Rhonda did.
Also,
if you're going to give this fight to,
let's say they do do it in July,
July,
whatever the UFC 200 you give holly six
months to know exactly what Rhonda
brings to the table and train for it.
Come up with a better game plan that she
had before and make sure that her
conditioning is on point,
makes your body's healthy,
rehabilitate any possible injuries she
might've had assessed to make sure she
doesn't overtrain but you got to
remember Rhonda shooting movies.
Well,
Holly Kia bud plant,
but when has anybody ever overtrained at
Jackson Winklejohn there's super smart
about that kind of shit.
Jackson is really fucking smart about
strategy.
He's really smart about preparation.
They've got some hardcore training
ethics in that gym.
Oh yeah,
and of course you got Winkeljohn who's
Winkeljohn was a fantastic kickboxer.
He's a really good coach and Jackson is
a really good strategist and they've got
excellent training partners and you've
got all this motivation about their
lineup.
You got Greg Jackson,
right?
He's like the fucking Yoda of MMA.
He's been doing it forever.
He's a genius game planner.
Then he got winkle John,
who's a phenomenal coach obviously,
and then he got izzy,
who does the wrestling,
does Jon Jones,
Israel Martinez.
He's a motherfucker,
Chicago man,
outstanding wrestling instructor and
he's good friends with my buddy Justin
Milo's,
who's my trainer.
Yeah.
With all that experience game planning
for,
for somebody just to,
you know,
it's becoming a,
what I love about mma now is it,
it really is about your team,
like just the brains behind you as well.
Just that strata has to be,
it has to be.
There are no lone wolves.
And you know,
and I had a conversation with John
before he moved to Albuquerque.
We had this conversation with may or may
not have been smuggled marijuana.
And uh,
we were in my hotel room in Montreal and
if he was,
you know,
before he won the title,
like way before,
and I said,
look dude,
I go,
you're an incredibly talented guy,
but you got to get all the right people.
The only way to do it right,
you can't do it on your own because
there's going to be a guy like you who's
also incredibly talented and that guys
can have the best team African.
That guy's going to get the best
training partners and that guy's going
to have the best strategist and that
guy's going to beat you.
And you might just beat you by an edge,
but that edge you could have overcome if
you had all that same coaching.
And I think a guy like John also,
he grew up with two super athlete
brothers,
one older,
one younger freaks.
And I think he recognizes that he's,
he might be special compared to the
average person to his brother,
not even in his own house.
His brother Arthur was doing mma.
I on the side,
like while he was playing for the NFL
and beaten John's ass job.
John [inaudible],
he's a heavyweight champ in high school.
His brother.
Yeah,
just pressing the fuck out of John.
And then the youngest brothers,
one of the best players in the NFL draft
pick.
So I think I want an,
John had a unique point of view as to
what freak athleticism really is and
about hard work and talent,
you know?
And it's just,
I think he just was getting by in the
UFC without having to go 100% as far as
his training and his preparation.
Hundreds going to be horrific.
If he really does get it really good,
he'll be the best of all time.
Didn't he say that?
Worst thing that happened to him was not
training for Gustafson and beating him
anyway.
And he said that that's probably,
he said it was trouble.
He was just like,
God I can do this and still get away
with you said it added and it was like
fuck it.
I'll just keep doing it.
Just speed.
This guy who trained the best campy that
are had in his life and I did nothing.
Still beat him.
Such a freak.
I'll tell you what,
how many,
how many fighters going to incorporate a
movement coach now after connor doing
all that shit out of them before I've
been obsessed with the Europa Pitaro for
I long time.
Well I'm,
I'm obsessed with him and I'm also
assessed with that guy that I'm Carlos
condit uses.
He does that move nat stuff.
I was watching a video on him training
today,
see if he could find,
I think I appreciate I retweeted it.
Um,
but he does all this crazy shit.
Like he's like doing chin ups with
trees,
like hanging off of trees and he's doing
balance beam stuff and they're throwing
sticks at him and he's catching them
while he's bouncing on stuff.
He's Ah,
he's at common for stuff.
He's even doing training specifically
for bow hunting.
He's got like reps that he does for bow
hunting while he's squatting and
standing up while holding a bow posture,
like to try to like solidify his balance
in precarious positions on hillsides.
Do that.
Erin make,
here's like some of the weird stuff that
Carlos is doing.
I mean Carlos is a really fucking smart
guy.
Really articulate.
So when he talked like let's play this
so we could hear it brings in the
beginning,
bring it to the beginning.
He's also been doing the same training
for about 20 years.
So this must be nice.
Bring it to the beginning first please.
There you go.
Somebody is watching a fight.
There's the punches,
the kicks,
the takedowns,
the grappling.
But what people are less aware of is,
you know,
for a fighter to be in correct position
to execute a strike effectively,
they need to have mastery of their
movement,
of their position,
of their balance.
I think that's really what separates the
elite fighters from somebody who's,
you know,
good enough.
Irwin and I have been training for about
seven to eight months.
People listening,
students walking outdoors,
balancing on a log.
I think one of the most challenging
things about training in nature is the
unpredictability.
It's talking about hae suffered an acl,
meniscus tear while signing move.
Nat definitely accelerated my recovery
in that I was not only doing these
movements and these different stretches
in physical therapy,
but also in my training sessions.
When Irwin and myself started training,
he looked at some of my previous fights
and he saw some things that my head
coach Greg Jackson saw independently.
They saw the same exact thing,
but what was great with working with
Irwin and working in the movement that
program is he specifically had exercises
and drills to make those changes.
Whereas,
you know,
some of my other coaches saw that it
needed to be made but weren't sure how
to get there.
This was extremely challenging for me.
We're trying to relearn something that
we may have lost that as adults having
sat in chairs or having laid on a bench
to do,
you know,
very linear stuff like bench press or
squat or whatever.
We've kind of lost that natural movement
ability and to gain it.
It takes a lot of focus.
I come home after I trained with Irwin
and I'm exhausted,
but as we go on and I have made these
adjustments in my body has adapted.
It's less and less mentally taxing and
you know,
more fun today.
You know,
today we had a blast for my last fight,
meaner when working specifically on
positioning of my body,
lower level stability in a,
in a lower stance position of my feet,
which helped me move forward and
backward quicker,
which I think ultimately really helped
me with the victor,
I was able to move in and out of range
effectively and land strikes and
ultimately get the win.
Wow.
I think that it's,
it's not just for elite athletes,
it's for,
for anybody.
It's,
you know,
it's,
anybody who wants to get in shape.
Anybody who wants to try something
different.
Maybe you were in the lifting or you're
into yoga or you know,
any different thing.
I hear all the time.
I'm plateauing,
I'm strong,
but I can't move.
I'm flexible,
but I have no power.
Ultimately,
we're trying to be the most functional
able bodied athlete,
person,
human that we can,
boom.
Interesting Shit,
man.
Yeah,
it is.
I'm gonna keep,
I'm gonna stick with Yoga.
I love that guys ponytail though.
I'm going,
I'm going out as a ponytail to his.
He does.
What's the fuck can we say?
Don't ever say his name.
Ida again.
Like I said,
it is.
He don't eat no pork spelled I d.
D.
O the ease.
You're calling me though.
Does he have a ponytail?
She certainly does.
He's a beautiful man.
I'm going to call him.
Hey,
don't take,
don't put that his name in your mouth.
Said Itto be respectful.
You don't had idle idle when you put my
second boyfriend name in your mom's
boyfriend.
I got two boyfriends and by the way,
cross counters,
the third boyfriend.
It's very hard for me to choose.
You line all those guys up in a jail
cell.
I have no idea who I got to choose,
but I would do her laundry.
I don't think you get to choose.
That's part of the program.
I don't do.
I think that guy's cool.
I think that stuff is cool.
I don't,
you know,
for certain guys that you don't know
unless you're doing it.
I won't train with vegans portal.
Wow.
Well here.
Oh,
his hair's pretty lucky.
Me Sir.
Pull them up please.
And show what he does.
Check this out.
Why does he do,
is there any videos,
great video know same shit.
No.
How did,
how did um,
fullscreen,
uh,
connor get connected to him?
I wonder,
uh,
he said that he was very interested in
connor.
He does some crazy stuff,
man.
Well,
you know what?
This is really similar to [inaudible] as
far as I'm looking at a movement,
not your,
all the stuff that Hixon Gracie,
he was really into.
But watch what he does.
He,
this is interesting really,
when you go back to,
cause like we thought of it as yoga and
it is yoga,
but wow.
Jesus Christ,
body it up.
This dude is doing handstand pushups on
the edge of a table.
Oh,
he's not,
he's not dropping his head below the
table.
Oh my God.
Look at these flips and shit.
He's watched it.
It's what the fuck?
Oh my God.
This guy's a super athlete.
Yes.
He is like what is his,
uh,
on another video that's called white
people breakdancing.
Oh,
this.
the same video.
It keeps going.
So what is his background?
Is he like age?
He's from Israel.
Look,
he was a shit.
He was a couple era guy.
Oh my God.
This is insane boxes.
He does gymnastics.
He talks about how important rings are.
You got to relax Brendan.
I won't relax.
I flip that.
He's doing that flickers.
Incredible.
Doing a one handed,
uh,
well,
she's essentially doing like Cirque de
Solei type shit dancing right there.
Moving.
What he'll do,
what he'll do is he'll make you,
he'll give you something to like,
he'll make you catch a stick and he
gives you a toy and as soon as you get
good at it,
he changed it up on you.
So he always has you guessing.
He always has you kind of deal.
He had connor on the balance beam's in
Santa Monica the week before the fight,
doing all sorts of crazy shit on the
beach.
But look at this guy's fucking ability
to move his body.
That's pretty shocked.
Buddied up.
I'll tell you right now,
cause it movement patterns.
He's right now,
connor wins with or without doing these
moments.
Hey to tell him,
know about that man.
I wonder if he's listen,
depending on who he's fighting.
I think these benefits,
these movements and learning how to move
your body like that,
we'll definitely benefit him.
And benefits are all the,
keeps you from winning or losing.
This is incredible.
This guy,
this is nuts,
man.
This kind of physical strength.
It's ridiculous.
It's a balance.
That's some stupid course.
Or maybe I'm just a hate.
I am not into this.
I'm us to hold on a second.
What do you mean you're not into it?
I'm just not into it.
Like what does that mean?
I'm not saying impressive.
That's cool man.
I've seen people in Yoga do it all the
time.
Listen,
you never like him.
He never seen the guy built like him.
It does that shit with that kind of body
mass.
Yeah.
I've never seen that in a million years.
I've never seen a guy be able to hold
those positions like that.
That's impressive.
Yeah.
I mean that's like a very small
percentage of the human population is
capable of moving their body.
Like I don't get it.
Like look at this.
Look what he's doing.
I know.
I'm sure.
That's great.
That looks very hard.
But why do you say you don't get it?
I'm saying I don't get the obsession
with it.
Like how fast you guys are into it.
One handed one hand Shannon ups,
dude,
you don't think that's incredible.
Yaps insane.
So what?
Why?
Why are you hating?
He gets it gets your
body.
That's what it is.
Body.
That's good for your shoulder joint.
Yeah,
I agree.
Jesus Christ get Super Mad when I have a
new boyfriend and that's the truth.
That's gymnasts isn't just a new
boyfriend thing.
It's him looking at this guy's body and
I'm,
and I just don't think it's that
impressive.
Well all your,
I go to yoga and I've seen gymnastics.
It's not anything new.
You're out of your mind and your mind if
you don't think that guys impressive.
I was going to say and looking at
meditating,
that's not impressive.
I can do that.
The only thing he's done so far that I
could do,
hey,
what's up everybody?
The
only thing that he's done so far though,
see this stuff is all the higgs and
Gracie type shed.
Hickson was really into this stuff,
super into it now.
Natural natural stuff,
um,
was essentially like this flowing yoga
style that Hickson was really into that
a lot of other Jujitsu guys get into it.
It's so interesting to see it all come
full circle now with guys like connor
incorporating that.
But this is even another level.
But you're,
you've seen those videos of Hixon doing
those um,
full splits,
standing full splits on a balance beam
20 years ago.
Yeah.
Holding his foot up in the air.
What do you try?
Why Saint?
You're hating that hixson now.
No,
no,
I'm sure you'll have to qualify.
Amazing.
I'm saying Hickson was doing and he was,
well this isn't,
you can't let,
it ain't chanting this route and was
doing camps.
Bas rutten was doing crazy.
Shavar did that.
Can't be in chance,
but he was in on chains and like,
fuck with his hair done.
You know what is,
what are you running from?
What are you running from my now?
Nothing.
I don't think you can give it that guy
that much credit.
Can I ask you a question?
Can I ask you an honest question?
Not doing that.
We're saying the guy's impressive
physically and that it helped connor to
train with that guy.
Obviously conor is not stupid.
He's figured out how to become the world
champion with one punch.
I mean,
he's not a stupid guy.
He's,
he's a marketing genius.
Common,
50 fives even more trouble.
Wait,
he's not cutting.
I don't know about that because a big
part of what gets him there is he cuts.
Wait,
perfect.
I mean he's,
oh,
he looks like he looks shit dog shit at
45,
but whatever he does to rehydrate the
next day,
he looks amazing.
And he's done it with no ivy this time.
Yeah.
But think if he doesn't have cut all
that weight so he doesn't deplete his
body,
but it's faster than all of these city
bigger guys,
it's going to take them down like Chad
did.
Then you've got a moisture problem.
Much bigger problem chat as a tiny guy
in comparison to a lot of 55 or it's
like dos Anjos dos Anjos gets on top of
you.
That is a totally different world of
physics.
And wait,
I agree.
But you look at matchups like co Donald
serone phenomenal match up.
Oh yeah.
Anthony Pettis.
Oh,
your best match shows are great.
Match up certain match ups that 55.
You're right,
you're right.
100%.
But,
um,
I think if you think of dos Anjos wins,
they'll fight.
Nope.
No.
It's only if calloway wins really cowboy
winds as the money.
That's the money.
That's the medical,
Ooh,
that is a mega fan.
Why do you guys say that w did not,
if just Sandhya this way.
No,
I'm,
I'm asking if he's so,
cause I think like Joe mentioned that
uh,
Dos Anjos can put in that Chad Mendez
game plan.
We'll also dos Anjos hits fucking hard
and he's got nasty Jujitsu.
He's got a fucking pressuring game.
But you know,
connor might laugh at it.
Connor might say,
you know,
like I got the solution to that look,
Jeremy Stevens,
doc,
that dude dead.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's very possible that connor might
just see holes in his game that we're
not seeing and he might be able to just
don't think a big payday like dos Anjos
Mcgregor's not a superstar fight.
Right.
It's really not.
But it is a superstar fight.
Whenever connor fights anybody and if
he's got a big challenge in front of him
fighting for the lightweight title,
it'll be a gigantic,
nope.
College big,
no matter what color cow bully,
that's the bucket.
If cowboy can win next Saturday against
dos Anjos would become the champion,
the world that is the,
and I guarantee you they'll probably
call connor out,
right?
Unless they,
unless it was a crazy war.
Like you want a rematch?
Yeah,
they don't like each other,
but unless it's a crazy war and you
know,
everybody says like you gotta do it
again.
And they both said we've got to do it
The UFC says they have to do again.
But again,
like this is like when people upset at
me about the Frankie Edgar thing,
like I don't get to call,
this is not my choice.
I'm not,
my opinion is just an opinion.
I just see a guy get knocked dead.
I see.
Okay,
that guy can't fight for at least six
months at least and really shouldn't be
fighting probably for a year.
And it wasn't much of a fight I ride
with right away.
I was like,
yeah,
Joe's right.
There's no way.
There's a rematch.
But then I thought about,
I'm like,
well,
they gave all these other champs
incident remains,
but they didn't decane cain got knocked
dead two against junior dos Santos.
He had a fight.
Big Foot.
Keep people get saying,
I can't get an instant rematch.
No,
he didn't.
It did.
Not More rematches then not.
But he fought big foot Silva and by the
way,
the Anderson Silva rematch to fucking
soon.
And I said it and he got,
he got lucky that he broke his leg.
How about that?
Not Obviously,
not really,
but he was getting beaten the fuck up.
He got hurt real bad and the clinch
Weidman caught him with a punch in the
clinch.
His legs went rubber.
He went to the ground,
he held on as much as he could and
Weidman beat the fuck out of him for
that first round.
And then Anderson threw that kick and
broke his leg.
And it was almost fortunate that he went
out like that because why?
Mum's going to beat his ass.
Anderson was not able to take a punch
anymore the same way he used to.
Anderson used to eat punches.
Watch the fight.
You want to watch a crazy fucking fight.
Watch his fight with Jorge Rivera where
he lets rivera punch him in the face.
Really lets him just punch with this.
Good in front of Rivera.
Let them pull it up.
I'm gonna.
Hey Rivera.
Jorge Rivera versus Anderson Silva in
cage wars in the UK.
This is before Anderson came to the
dude.
I was a gigantic Anderson Silva Fan long
before everyone that title I will you
watch my calling the fight against Chris
Weidman.
I was a kid in a fucking candy store
because he wasn't a,
he wasn't a new guy to me.
Like you're saying when he fought Chris
Leben who I say Weidman,
I meant [inaudible] sorry.
When he fought Chris Leben,
when he came to central seating,
it was crazy.
I was a kid in a candy store cause I was
like fuck this.
This guy is a different kind of stryker.
Yeah,
this is a whole different animal you're
dealing with like in Lehman's gonna come
forward.
Face first.
The tailor made
this.
So Jorge Rivera who was on the left,
who is a fucking hard punch,
good hand and Anderson standing right in
front of them and there's a one point in
the fight.
How long does this fight go,
Jamie?
10 minutes.
There's one point,
the fight before Anderson knocks him out
where Anderson stands right in front of
them and literally lets him punch him in
the face and Markdale [inaudible] who
was with Jorge was like,
yeah,
yeah.
And he's like,
what the fuck?
You should hear mark talk about it.
Mark.
It's a hilarious mark talks about it,
but I love that guy.
He's so funny.
By the way,
mark was also agreeing with me that all
though look different physically.
He like,
he looks smooth,
he looks the entire world except for
South America.
Agreed with you joe.
Well,
there's some people on the underground
that disagree.
We call Zack cody.
It's just when you see a guy,
it's hard to tell from a a still photo
as well.
A lot of what you see is in movement.
You see like in the like they don't look
as as explosive.
Even the still photo,
it shows a little bit,
but not much.
It could,
like I said,
it could have been attributable to
cardio.
I mean is let's say,
let's say,
well,
there's no evidence at all.
They'll ever did steroids,
right.
So let's say he never did steroids,
let's say he just did way more cardio
for that fight and didn't do nearly as
much strength training and that's what
it is.
There's a difference in the way it
looks.
[inaudible] Silva was the biggest,
that was the big contrast and the door
of course [inaudible] it's public,
but the tour,
we knew to look for it.
We knew it was happening.
We knew about the testing,
we knew about everything with Eric
Silver.
You're like hall.
Yeah,
he was.
He was so bonded out with that apple
bottom and everything too.
When he walks in and he's taught here,
when he walked into the octagon,
it was literally like a scooby doo sound
all across the globe.
Canny panty drawer.
No,
no,
no.
That's what I mean.
In the last fight crisis in the last
fight,
last buys,
melted cheese,
it just didn't make any sense.
But again it could have been that he
changed his approach.
He decided his gas and out in these
fights like against Matt Brown,
he gassed out and he has all this muscle
and all this power and he's always going
for it and he is a young guys.
I ain't even 30 years old.
It is possible that he just changed his
entire approach.
No more strength and conditioning,
only just training,
only cardio from a sparring and from you
know,
repetition.
I mean it's totally possible.
It's totally possible elster over him.
When he got busted,
it was in this protein shake to look how
beautiful Anderson's movement.
It was like,
oh,
he checked that kick.
I mean it's all like automatic when he
was in.
By the way,
he didn't come to the UFC until,
I think he was like 35 man,
look at him.
He was going to retire with four is
going to retire.
No,
talked them out of it.
How old was he when he came to the UFC?
His third tour?
I thought it was 32 you might be right
though.
I know he's going to retire and he might
be right.
Eggnog talked them out of it.
It was like you have to fight.
While he had had some,
you know,
crazy tough fights.
He also had a falling out with shoot the
box.
Surprise.
He's not retiring now.
Why,
why do you think he still went to Moitai
Dream Team and it be like he,
they created a team and he didn't have
good training partners and there was a
lot of shit going on,
but he pulled it together right when he
came to the UFC.
Traditi ever.
And will he pull it together in cage
wars?
Really?
And then he came to the UFC after that.
I remember he was about to fight Roy
Jones and then everyone's like,
Nah,
that would have been so ridiculous.
Been awesome.
He got
lit up.
It would have been awesome.
Oh good.
Wake up call to a lot of MMA fighters.
They think they can box with the garlic
Jones.
Speaking of John,
she says,
get knocked down in the fourth round.
Hey,
stop doing that.
You're a head lead commentate on HBO.
It's not do that.
Yeah.
And I think that's going to fuck with
his commentary for sure.
Hundred percent not going to be able to
talk that good after that knockout.
I mean,
it'll be a while before he recovered
that he's had like five of those.
I mean,
unless he's getting paid crazy amounts
of money,
I don't get why he does it.
No one really watched it blinked.
The reason we watched cause he got
highlight,
knockout,
you know,
meanwhile Jorge Rivera did a lot better
than rich Franklin.
It's interesting.
He sure did.
I figured out how to,
well,
Jorge's it Moitai guys,
I figured out how to fight Anderson from
the clinch Anderson like at this point
in the fight is sorta just chipping away
at them.
But uh,
how much more time is in this fight?
How much,
where are we at?
There's a,
the moment before the fights dot.
That nice knee to the body.
See,
this is Anderson,
like really in his prime.
So you see Anderson,
John Jones shadowbox into yeah,
it's pretty cool.
Interesting,
right?
Addison against that of rockhold called
Luke rockhold beat him out.
Oh God.
It's horrible.
Now it's over.
Now.
The champ,
the new crown champions,
the old Anderson Silva.
No,
Anderson's,
it's,
oh,
look at him.
Let me,
let me,
yeah,
you're crunk for the Ken Shamrock Holy
Space.
You fight to Anderson took them down.
Unless you are on testosterone
replacement,
when you hit your late thirties like
that,
there's just no way you can't compete.
I compete in it.
Look,
if you got Anderson on the Vito Belfort
Diet,
I think Anderson goes back in there like
a demon and,
and who knows who he can beat until his,
you know,
40th fucking birthday or whatever it
would be when the wheels fall off.
But Anderson,
now you're talking about a guy who was
brutally owed by Chris Weidman and then
in the second fight had a seriously hard
time staying conscious from a punch in
the clinch.
You know,
I just don't,
I don't think the body,
I think the body can only take so much
man.
And I think he took it all.
Victoria Anderson makes sense.
Here's where it gets,
here's towards the end of the fight.
This is the second round where I'm
pretty sure he stopped him the second
round.
But,
um,
there's a point where it's just fucking,
let me start.
Show me how much time is left here.
Yeah,
scoot ahead a little bit and see if we
could find it because it's fucking
preposterous.
Andersen to standing of fraud of them.
Here it is right here.
Watch this and listen.
Just stands in front of them and let's
Jorge tee off on his face.
Look at this.
Boom,
boom,
look standard,
right?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Blog.
Just just ate.
It just stood in front of him.
And eight.
Now contrast that,
that series of punches that Jorge Rivera
who hits fucking hard to Chris Weidman's
one punch in the clinch.
Oh,
night and day.
That dropped him.
I understand.
Just can't absorb shots like he used to.
He used to have a phenomenal chin.
You shut down,
your brain says,
oh,
here comes to chocolate dental.
Same thing.
Had a phenomenal chin.
I mean there was times and Chuck's life
where you just weren't going to hurt
him.
Sorry.
I think Dan's Dan Henderson pretty much
until he got killed by Vito.
Same thing.
Yeah,
you can eat everything.
Who Do you guys have winning the
Anderson Silva RFC [inaudible] that's
not going to happen.
Veto won't fight them.
I talked to Renzo for teeth.
Why won't he fight him?
Veto it.
Doesn't want to fight him.
He wants a shot at the title and they're
like,
dude,
you,
you fought for the title and got smoked
in the first round.
You can't beat Dan Henderson and get a
new title shot.
Luke wants to fight him because he wants
to fight.
Vetoer he should.
They said he goes,
I want LFV tour and the silver platter.
Yeah,
he's going to cause that what?
He said,
yes.
That's going to be ugly for Vito.
I feel set it up.
Well look,
you got to do Weidman.
Weidman to Weidman rematch would be very
interesting.
Um,
uh,
rockhold Yoel Romero fight would be very
interesting.
I think were a marrow is not doing
anything in the fourth and fifth round.
All Jesus.
And remember I was the guy,
Jesus,
he's saying forget.
He said Fuck Gay.
Do you know that trout just drove me
crazy when the,
whoever interviewed him didn't clarify
that.
They like,
oh cool.
They didn't know either.
Well,
fucking knew.
I was listening to what he's saying.
Forget he's Cuban.
Don't forget Jesus.
When I speak to them,
you notice when I speak to him,
I looked at him right in the eye.
I speak very clearly and I tried to
clarify everything he says.
Like when he fought,
uh,
Tim Kennedy,
and there was that moment where you
didn't get off the stool.
I had a long conversation with them.
I was talking to him nice and slowly.
I'm looking at,
I'm trying to find out what he's saying.
I'm trying to get to it.
I've known a lot of Cuban people.
I know what they sound like.
They have that way of saying teas.
It's why the t is a why there's not for
gay.
Jesus
had been the PR team.
If I was interviewing,
kind of fucked up my saying.
So you're saying don't forget Jesus CCC.
Don't forget Jesus.
No,
he,
it sounds like he's saying no for Gay
Jesus.
No,
he's tall.
He feels like he's like five,
eight,
five,
nine.
Oh no,
he's,
he's probably,
uh,
there's how gay Jesus,
no.
Yoel Romero had the flu for the last
four days.
Come on,
Milky.
Don't ever got to show that guy to get
him up here.
That guy wanted to come on the podcast
with John Jones and he's like,
I'll say some crazy shit.
John won't say.
I'm like,
what?
Who's America?
Why would we want youth?
It was Matt,
John John's manager.
Great guy though,
by the way.
Just fucking around.
But he's the idea of like what your son,
but he's like,
you're going to talk for John.
That's exactly what I don't want.
Yeah.
I want to know what's going on in his
mind,
but go fuck cheese out.
Poor guy.
He got tortured online.
Like people were mad at him like even
like reputable,
like sports broadcasters were tweeting
at how are horrendous.
What he said was and terrible.
What he said was,
I was fucking yelling at my computer.
He said,
forget.
He says the same gags that do the
ranking and they can't even get your oil
shit straight.
No,
no,
I don't do tr under the rankings kings.
How's,
there might be an undercut or no,
let's do the rankings.
I'm pretty sure,
right?
Some some head journalists.
What do you do that
who does it make more sense?
Yes.
Ryan seacrest who does the ranking?
Oh,
where does that,
like what?
What are the people,
who are the people?
The reikis aren't that horrible.
I just think that when you know someone
like Uriah Hall knocks out Gig Arbonne
Saucy and he's below him on the
rankings,
that's fucking stupid.
Well you know the UFC brass was like we
can't do the rankings because it's some
bullshit.
Cause whenever they're going to do,
they're going to do pay dictate.
That's based off your ranking.
And then that was hard.
Then they're like,
oh fuck,
we can't do that because bill,
he's a huge fan of whoever he's lost
seven in a row and they want to ranking
number 10 do you have any idea,
do you guys have any idea how much a
veteran makes off a UFC?
I off the robot.
Let's not even talking about it cause
I'll start throwing up on my keyboard
to,
yeah,
that's the answer.
You know what?
Can I do a positive spin though?
I hit on Reebok so much.
Can I do a positive one?
I dug the mcgregor trunks,
the green and gold trunks and all those
black and gold for the first time ever.
First time ever.
I was like,
those look good.
Well they were there,
you know,
they're responding to criticism and
doing a good job of responding to
criticism.
I disagree.
I think the whole,
the real reality of this whole situation
is that it could have been all been
handled better.
I think everybody would agree to that.
And I think the fighters are very
disappointed at their lack of ability to
be autonomous as far as like how much
money they can make from sponsors.
And like you're the perfect example.
You know,
I,
and I've used you as an example and you
know,
people said that you weren't telling the
truth and you know,
now we know that that's not not correct.
You brought me my fund,
your financials,
and I brought them to the fucking top.
Yes.
And we had a nice conversation about it
and I think that it's,
it's a,
it's an unfortunate reality that we're
going to have to live with now.
And I would,
I would like to see out of this is,
I mean the argument against it was like
people are having condom depo on their
trunks on that shit.
I'm like,
well how about don't have condom depot?
How about you have you,
you,
you make a very specific like,
listen,
you can get all the sponsors you want,
but you can't have anything that's going
to be bad for the image of the UFC.
This is what we think are bad.
I don't know why Khan,
which is what they did by the way.
I don't know why condoms will be bad.
Is it bad to not get aids?
Exactly what it was.
It was bandaid depot.
Would that be okay?
But aspirin depot was that okay.
You have to submit your sponsors to
check them off so you weren't allowed to
alcohol,
tobacco,
anything competed with the UFC.
Did anybody,
did it really diminish the entertainment
value for anybody when someone was
walking with dynamic fastener on their
shirt,
did he give a fuck at all?
I will never give a fuck if Chris
Weidman was walking to the octagon and
he had muscle farm or fucking fill in
the blank,
you know,
fucking where all those logos now
they're on the mat.
That's what bonds.
Some of them are.
Most of the map looks like a nascar.
The fighters are in black and white.
Unless you're a champ looking like
assholes get not getting paid.
That's the only issue I have with it.
Well there's,
there's definitely something to be said
about that because none of that money is
going towards the fighters and the
cause.
The only thing that's changed besides
the fighters look in plain as fucking
black and white is the matte looks like
a fucking toys are us now.
Yeah.
I think there's a real,
uh,
option,
a real possibility for fighters to get
super involved in social media and put
out a lot of videos and get people
excel.
If you put out a lot of content,
people respond and they loved like this.
A lot of people that I follow.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people that I follow.
You know Ross training,
you know at Ross training guy in
instagram?
No,
he is like some pretty uh,
intense,
uh,
personal trainer dude.
He's got all these great workout things
that he does on instagram.
I follow that guy all the time.
If he was a fighter and he had all these
people following him all the time,
or a lot of other guys that do these
things where girls who do these things
too,
there's a lot of people that will girls,
they do it.
They won't look at their asses.
Man,
I followed Jeff.
I know you do
get his head.
[inaudible] the way I talk when I'm
talking about either mortality or voice
just got too,
but I think that what it gives an
opportunity for fighters to adjust and
the adjustment is to concentrate or have
someone that works where you concentrate
on social media,
put out a lot of content.
I know miles jury does a lot of shit
bomber though.
It is about,
we shouldn't have to do it.
It would be better if they didn't.
There's so many fighters.
That's why if I'm conor mcgregor rate
for this,
if I'm coming or greg or I say I'm not
doing shit to give me 20 million of
fight,
that's how much power I think that kid
has right now.
He has the most power I've ever seen a
UFC fighter.
Yeah,
he's a nation behind him.
He could sell out 80,000 okay,
well I'm going to show you what kind of
power he has behind him because I'm
going to send these to Jamie and we're
gonna Watch what it was like at the mgm
cause.
I have videos of Irish people going
fucking bonkers at a level that you've
never seen in your entire life.
We're talking about climbing on top of
fucking casino tables,
screaming,
taking their shirts off.
There's thousands of them.
When he was there,
when he won,
he won.
He's a bigger star than lesnar now.
They stormed the fucking casino and when
they stormed the casino,
nobody could do anything about it.
Nobody can do anything about the
security guards are all standing around.
I'm going to show you some.
We've never seen a star like this,
and for the first time connor's bigger
than the UFC.
He can go,
I want this amount of money,
or I'm not doing shit.
And he just backed up everything he
said.
Yeah,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna say Jamie right now.
You never seen nothing like this.
Irish love him some fighting.
Jamie,
you got your phone on his Tiger Tattoo
bums me out a little bit.
I'm not going to Lydia.
WHATSAPP.
Jame
airdrops not showing up.
Airdrop is really wonky,
man.
You need to get one on your computer
airdrop.
Don't you have a phone?
Turn it on.
It's like,
oh yeah.
Should I email it to you?
Is that the better move?
Okay,
let me get you all to you.
Um,
you,
uh,
you wouldn't believe it.
You're going to,
you're going to look at this and you get
to go.
What?
The mob to attachments maximum.
All right.
Don't just sell them.
They use yesware.
I wouldn't be at that casino.
Yeah.
Crowds make me nervous.
Should I get rid of there right away?
I get out of that.
I don't.
Yeah,
you had to get out of there right away.
And I'm like,
mom,
this is so ridiculous.
Nervous.
Am I send you a couple of other ones,
Jamie?
It's just so stupid.
It was so crazy.
It was.
I'm ever seen anything like that.
You know what to pay out of my huge
total,
total new level of chaos and,
and,
and really it was amazing,
man.
I tweeted,
right,
right when he knocked him out,
I said,
well ladies and gentlemen,
this is your biggest star in UFC
history.
How about arguably one of the biggest
stars in the history of all combat
sports?
Because there's never been anybody that
has won a fight that has had casinos
overrun where the literally the security
guy watch these videos.
You're going to freak out.
The security guys can't do shit.
Dudes are jumping up on tables.
They're taking their shirts off their
singing all together.
I mean,
not just one or two thousands and
thousands of these army guys.
Did it come to you?
It does now.
He's a special dude,
man.
Yeah.
The thing why I'm just drawn to connor
is cause he's a good person like you see
as soon as it'd be,
although yeah.
Hugged him.
Done the mic.
Cause like he's a great champion and
I'll respect picture of them hugging in
the back.
Yeah,
man,
I saw it.
Yeah.
It's very cool man.
He's an amazing,
like he's just a good person all change
again.
If they said it'll route match.
Yeah,
correct.
You're right back up.
Did you see the picture that he put on
twitter?
Yes.
That's so rude.
Is a picture of him Jay.
Wait,
wait until Brian come back.
Cause Brian Well,
how about we do don't do it.
Well Brian,
doable.
Brian's gone.
Brian doesn't declare that as an ex
boyfriend jack off.
But this is a photo of Connor Connor's
looking down and uh,
the camera's like looking up at him and
says,
wake up Jose.
It's all over.
God.
He can do what he called Solo bulleted.
It's a marketing thing.
You know what I'm saying?
It's brilliant.
That's cool.
But it's also real.
It's a mock cause he ain't got a tall
that's on his twitter.
It's cold blood.
It's cold as cold blooded.
That's,
that's like a,
that's cryotherapy blood.
It's so fun stuff.
It's like fucking dilute picture
resurface because he posted that weeks
ago.
Oh,
did it?
Yeah.
And then they just re posted it.
He posted,
he repost pickup was brilliance all over
fuck.
And I seen that photo of him call it.
Did you see that?
He tweeted that came out today and he's
on the bike and Venice going Dadadadah.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's,
it's kind of hilarious.
What are you looking for Jimmy?
Just look it up.
Google it.
You Fuck?
Oh look right here.
Yeah,
him verse.
Frankie's a motherfucking,
maybe it's on instagram.
I wasn't there either.
No,
wait.
Took it down.
No Way.
Hmm?
You did you look under media,
this picture of this Russian hammer
time.
How long has that from a go?
How long ago?
Hmm.
There's no way it took it down.
Did he take it down?
Okay.
Tammy's is in square feet from today.
Just one.
Was it an instagram post?
Let's see.
Um,
they take it down.
Is that possible?
No,
just found it,
Jamie.
It's right there.
It's it.
I googled it in three seconds.
How dare you,
how dare you call,
pull it up.
Google it.
Okay.
So this is,
let's just play this while we're waiting
for you to get your shit together.
Oh,
that's the [inaudible]
now,
um,
show some of the other ones because
there's some other ones in the actual
casino itself that's in the lobby of the
casino.
Nuts.
It's fucking mad.
That's the same thing.
The second series that I sent you.
Yeah.
Is Madness,
man.
Just absolutely madness thing like this
with this following that Irish.
I mean,
they just love fighting in their blood.
And then you got this,
fuck the Muhammad.
I'll leave Ireland now and then some,
right.
Ireland was always a,
always had battled with itself.
Ireland because of the topography of
Ireland.
It would break up into what they called
to us,
like clans and villages,
and they would always fight with each
other.
So I don't want to hear a fucking
history lesson.
So here's the,
here's the image,
see if he can find it.
Okay,
well,
I was,
uh,
it says Penn didn't Dot Co.
Dot.
UK.
You can find it there.
It's a whole thing.
Wake up chosen.
It's all over.
They've never had an a star like this.
They've always wanted it.
Even even guys who you know left on
their shield,
we get knocked out but came back.
They loved them.
They were stars.
Now you have legit fucking superstar.
A murderer.
Yeah,
I guy was mark and people.
I mean to go through all that,
the crazy UFC promo where they're
meeting in the middle of the fucking
strip and the fans behind them and the
million dollar fucking production value
of the commercial,
the giant world tour.
And then I'll pulls out of the first
fight shows up for the second fight and
one fucking punch.
Deads them.
I mean that is hit right.
You can't write that
shit crazy.
That is a movie and a half.
That is the greatest superstar that
country has ever known.
An all combat sports.
This is,
well,
that's just the image.
If you go to the actual website,
it's right there.
Jamie.
Come on man.
I'm Paul.
I just showed you how to get it.
I googled it while I'm talking.
It's ain't hard to do.
You're not mad.
No,
no.
He loves it.
He's no Anita Portafab that whatever it
says right there underneath it.
By the way,
Eve Edwards called me and left me a
message.
He goes,
hey dude.
Um,
I heard something weird.
Did you come out of the closet?
Are you gay?
And then I've got another call from
Karen.
Same thing going,
hey dude,
I heard you were gay.
I was like,
where are you hearing that?
I came around in the candle.
How about you just got done for 20
minutes?
Slobbered over Luke rockhold maybe
people aren't having ido portal.
You think people at first of all ido
portal.
Don't make me say it again.
You know what I'm saying?
It is.
Wake up Jose.
It's all over.
Oh,
go back.
So you could see it all the way.
Look at this.
Oh,
look at that fucking photo.
That is December 1st.
That is just ridiculous.
Wow.
So that's an old photo that he reposted.
Yes.
Cause it came true.
Wow.
Interesting.
That's flat.
Two Tigers.
Just too real to be cool.
You know what I'm saying?
It looks like three d.
Yeah.
It's not a good placement.
It's just when it's what you would get
the apps like that man show the abs off.
He,
I guess he doesn't give a fuck what he
looks like though.
You know what?
As far as that goes to it doesn't have
to do whatever.
He wants to come bitches out making
money.
Tell him the UFC.
What the fuck to do?
What is he going to do when he retires?
I mean the amount of y'all some juice,
it's going to be awesome juice and
adrenaline and excitement that's going
through his veins right now.
Just the fucking electricity right now.
Like a promoter.
There'll be a promoter.
How do you have shut the fuck up.
How do you ever,
how do you ever match that?
It's all downhill from here.
Down here.
You might go landscape style and dying a
small plane crash.
He might,
I could see that.
I just don't,
I don't know like a guy like this is
like the level of fame.
Look at it.
Some guy got on top of the line in the
fucking Mgo security,
uh,
off the line,
sir.
That's where we draw the line.
They don't give a fuck.
You seem in the streets beforehand.
Did you hear about the Irish guys were
on their way to vegas and they have to,
they kicked off the flight for fighting.
Yeah.
Didn't even make it a lot.
They didn't even make it to the fight.
Conor mcgregor fan did.
My buddy went to a soccer game in
Ireland.
They,
they didn't get to the stadium.
There were so many fights.
It was nuts.
It's just what they do.
Yeah,
they're fucking animals.
It could be like a big ass movie stars.
Oh yeah.
He says he's gotten offers.
He's not hold him for that.
You know what he's doing is smart and
what Rondo did was not smart in that
regard,
that she got distracted and spread
herself thin.
Took all of that short money,
you know,
it's a lot of money,
but took it all.
Whereas Khan or like no danks
I don't think any more than,
I don't think it made a difference.
I think Holly Holm is a different
fighter.
I think she met a different file.
It's certainly made a difference.
Brian,
when you distract yourself,
you are distracted.
That I understand.
I understand.
This is what this is Brian standing up
for distractions.
Holly Holm is a hot,
much higher level striker and would have
been regardless.
I don't,
I don't think,
I just don't think,
uh,
you can come meet with somebody like
that.
Who's that far advanced as a striker?
Well,
certainly not striking and she's
stronger than Rhonda.
That's what it looked like to me.
He's drunk as fuck.
Yeah.
Well you know,
she's definitely leaner,
you know,
and it looks more muscular and bigger
and she's fought as high as 152 pounds.
And Rhonda,
correct me if I'm wrong,
it's not a big double leg,
single lecture.
She,
she's a junior person who just got to
get her hips close to you.
So when she has people who in her camp,
like this guy is,
he or whoever it is who can neutralize
that judo,
push your hips away,
drop level when she gets close,
no drop in levels.
Men,
here's the big thing,
they just avoided that left arm.
Rhonda always ties up with that left
arm.
Yeah,
I mean she does the same approach and
almost all of our fights and it works on
this amateur and it's not,
that's a good way of putting it.
It's not to say that like she doesn't
have other approaches,
but that is the approach that she's most
comfortable with and she goes to more
often.
And when it wasn't working,
you know,
you fuck you that you had,
you had that camp game planning and
they've seen a lot and I feel like
they've gained plan for very,
very good fighters who are men who have
a lot more complex.
And Rhonda for those guys was probably
much easier to game plan.
And then they had holly Holm who has
been striking.
I'm not talking to you,
man,
man.
You know what I mean?
Old men like the guy's eyes.
I fuck guys like me.
Hey,
hey,
you don't know that.
Well,
I just heard he came out of the closet.
I,
that's what I heard from eve.
I don't Rhonda doing movies and these
distractions.
That's,
that's on her team.
That's not wrong.
Yes.
People go,
you should do this.
No,
you're fine.
You're so much better than we know that
she's got some shit advice coming her
way.
But what is from a lot of people?
Yes.
What is her camp like?
You've,
you've been close to her while she's
training.
Like what is her camp like?
Uh,
you know,
I'm not gonna go into crazy detail.
All I know she works harder than anyone.
So if she gets with the right people,
she's going to be a lot better.
If she gets with the right team that
says,
maybe don't do this movie right now,
maybe let's save this move after you
beat holly.
Maybe let's do this then.
It's not a problem now too,
because if she's prepping for the
rematches and she,
we're about to go do that roadhouse
and isn't a problem.
That roadhouse movie,
like movies are hard to sell when you're
a bad ass.
When the world knows and that your last
fight,
you got flat lined.
I would suggest it wouldn't be
surprising to me the way Hollywood
Hollywood works there,
where they go.
A lot of this movie is built on you
being the baddest girl on the planet and
undefeated.
Don't be surprised if sometimes those
kinds of movies fall through or they
downgrade or maybe they just don't
happen.
I wonder what kind of contract is
involved.
She's got like big
time movie agents,
like a wonder if that was like built in
protection against that shit.
I would assume there is.
If I'm Dana White,
I go look at me,
you're not doing amy fucking movies,
your contracts with us.
We're not giving permission to do any of
this.
So anyone who says yes,
you can make a movie and still beat
Holly,
I fire right now.
Anyone who goes,
you can do this and still do and still
be world champion is full of Shit.
It's just not true.
What do you think about her fighting
holly in July?
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know man.
What the fuck she going to do if you
shoot,
if she'd make,
if she's filming roadhouse while Holly's
focused,
like you just talked,
call you the other day,
right?
Well she wanted to train.
She wants to go right back to the gym
after the fight.
Yes.
She might have gone to a fucking hotel
room and hit pads and Rhonda can eat
solid foods and then she's going to make
a movie and then jump into camp in the
same camp that has been telling her to
do all this stuff,
you know,
and the same,
it's tough man.
God,
God blessed her.
Hopefully shit works out but it's a
mother fucker man.
It is a motherfucker,
right?
If you wanted to get ready for a fight
like that,
you would want to go through a battery
of physical tests like as far as your
brain goes,
cat scans,
Mris like that was a fucking wall up she
took.
And when you know,
well I've had people on like Doctor
Rhonda,
Patrick and Dr. Mark Gordon who talk
about the damage to the pituitary gland
and what happens when you get chaos like
that and how important rest is in
recovery and how long it takes to
recover from something like that.
And then we saw the,
the Anderson fight that we're just
talking about how Anderson,
he's take this tremendous punch.
Then he fought Weidman and you know,
it wasn't the same guy anymore.
Like to jump right back in like this,
look at,
look at Mendez to Mendez,
gets knocked out by connor,
gets right back in there.
We've never seen him get dropped.
So he's not just drop flatline with one
file.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean he came back and,
and frank,
he's not,
you know,
Frankie's a motherfucker man.
He throws combos and he's very active
and he stays,
you know,
he's more of a barrage of punches and
Combo Poncho.
But Frank is not a knockout artist by
any means.
And there's also the factor of kind of
getting,
I wonder,
I would imagine any fighter who gets in
the ring and realizes that they are
just,
that's a riddle that's very hard to
solve right now.
I would imagine for Ronda,
as great as she is and this athletic or
she has,
you know,
there's no doubt that Holly Holm looked
like she was just far advanced in how to
dispatch somebody with kicks and she was
disguising her cakes,
punching and stuff like that.
I would imagine there's an emotional
factor which is,
can I even do this?
Can I solve this riddle riddle in six
months?
That's a,
that's not a lot of time to catch up to
somebody who's that good.
Also to let all the dust settle.
As far as like the devastation to your
motions,
your confidence or you know Ron does his
very special kind of pit bull.
Is She chomping at the bit to get back
in there?
I mean is she like,
she's just straight up spreading.
She's a special person and don't think
there's a middle ground either.
I think she's going to come back and
just be a fucking demon or we're going
to see a shell and she's going to get
fucking kicked in the face again and we
never see her again.
I don't want to see it.
I don't think there's a middle ground.
Even if she comes back in fucking
phenomenal shape and gets fired up and
motivated and does everything the right
way and no distractions.
Holly might still mark.
I agree.
Still don't have the skills to stand
there with,
with,
and move in.
And she goes,
she can't take holly down.
She's hot.
And not only that,
what of Holly's game plans even
different this time.
What if she moyie ties?
They'll fuck out of those legs.
Cause let me tell you something about
Holly Holm.
That girl's got legs like a
thoroughbred.
See Her bouncing around the Austin and
do those flip flips.
Well,
who's got Brian Keller Hawks Game Plan
for you?
Greg Jackson right now,
or the ladder over in Glendale.
You know what I'm saying?
You got sick,
you got six,
you got six months,
son.
Wow.
Six months of the mad scientist Greg
Jackson going,
this is what we did this time.
This is where we're gonna do this time.
And Mike Winkeljohn and Izzy and Izzy.
Yikes.
Oh,
and that she has confidence.
Oh and John Jones in her camp and they
trained together.
I'd fake an injury.
That's what I do.
Yeah.
I mean she wants to fight her.
I mean she thinks she's going to get me,
she's going to get images.
It's going to get eat.
She's going to get eaten up by Holly
Holm.
Well,
do you know all due respect and Misha is
not going to fight that way.
She's not going to charge after a
different animal.
It's a different fight.
It's,
I don't know who would fight me.
She is me.
She's got a different style of
takedowns.
She'll shoot for doubles if she gets to
clinch,
she'll very,
her approach.
She's got ricky lundell working with her
who was also an excellent coach and
coach.
She's got some good things going for it.
And then you know what you're dealing
with also is when you see a fight or get
into the octagon,
you don't know what kind of injuries
they've had.
You don't know what they're dealing with
in training camp that they're trying to
overcome.
Like when Luke rockhold said after the
fight they had staph infection.
Like I talked to Bob Cook about it.
Bob Cook right when I go congratulate,
she goes,
he almost fucking pulled out of the
fight.
I go,
what?
He goes,
yeah,
he's just had really bad staff.
He's been on antibiotics for two weeks
ago.
You fucking kidding me because you never
know.
When holly fought Raquel Pennington,
she did not look very good.
And that was one of the reasons why I
didn't think that was a good fight to
have right now.
She had a split decision victory over
Raquel Pennington.
I mean,
Raquel almost beat her.
She came within a hair of beating her.
Let me ask you this,
Joe,
with,
you know,
with these,
I want to say more well rounded
athletes.
Whenever we see a fighter who charges
like it's almost no skill just to rush
forward,
they get fucked up by the better
fighter.
See,
Aldo fucked up,
Rhonda fucked up.
We see these people,
they also fight.
So emotionally come straight forward and
then you see the more talented find it
like what the fuck pink.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
Can't do it.
And it was way more successful than Aldo
at it and she,
she's fighting less for competitions.
So it worked well.
Holly's a fucking Hoe for women.
Holly is very high level,
high level it,
well not only didn't work,
but she ate a lot of shots before one,
it took her ass.
That's what I'm saying,
the superior athletes who it's like,
you're going to rush forward and do
what?
I'm want to fuck you up.
Right.
Rhonda does have a fucking phenomenal
Chin if you,
I don't,
hopefully still,
but you look at the shots that she took
that fucking elbow at one elbow that
clean as she's coming after she blasts
or in the job with our mom.
We ever seen her get hit by a really
good strike.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you know,
it was one of the things that we were
discussing before the fight of like what
you got to watch out for holly.
Um,
when we're doing the pre preflight
breakdown,
I was like,
she's so good at shielding our kicks
with punches.
You don't see him coming.
She's hitting you at the end of these
punches.
And then the kicks already coming.
You know,
when you watch our RFA fight,
it was an RFA.
She fought and we'd watch all her other,
um,
MMA fights and smaller organizations,
those kicks come out of nowhere,
man.
You know,
and she,
she knows when to land them.
You know,
she doesn't show them until she's ready
to land them and they'll buy blanks.
You see a parade in Albuquerque,
20,000 now.
Really?
20,000 people came out to see her in
Albuquerque.
She told me,
she told me she's happy to be in vegas
cause at least it's relaxed.
Gosh,
she can't go anywhere in Albuquerque.
She said she tried to take uh,
she tries to go to a restaurant and have
a meal.
There's a line of people at her table
that want to take photos with sauce and
put food in her mouth.
That's exhausting.
That,
that's,
that's managing champion ship.
Managing for tension for those people
are fucking rude.
Don't know.
Mess with someone when they're eating.
That is what it was later.
Well for tall,
I can't believe I'm seeing you,
Holly Holm.
I don't care about your state.
What about me?
Oh you think you're too good for me.
Deal with it.
You deal with that in a crazy way.
Oh,
I don't deal with it like she deals with
it.
I like that 70 people waiting in line to
deal with some shit you deal with.
Ebi is like,
good Lord Man.
Are we ever going to get in here?
Yeah.
It gets a little weird but it doesn't
get,
it's also different because I'm a man
like there's not a bunch of people
looking to rape me.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like grape and holly Holm.
She,
she didn't kick you right in the deck.
The deck.
Go ahead and try and shut pancake that
Dick here.
So a couple of girls,
you don't want to try and read a screen
and do that hike,
hike,
that time hitting mitts.
Now I make the I holly home.
The people are like,
is that Holly Holm?
Nah,
it's Brian Callen.
Holy Shit.
He's got the same thing.
I can tell the difference when you hear
the impact.
I don't know man.
I don't know.
I got Chris,
I got crisp,
crisp strike.
I've seen you kicked the bag and it was
very sad.
That's not true.
That's not true because I wasn't opening
up.
If I open up when I open up dust or
killed,
well,
when I do this,
but my next duty is going to have a full
like gym set up.
I'll let you kick it out.
We'll videotape.
It's going to be scary,
but you're gonna let me three quarter,
you're going to kick and then you're
gonna kick trying to do that and I won't
do that.
I kicked very hard.
Don't make,
They call me,
they call me Brian.
My nickname,
when I find them,
you don't have a dick next.
I do it.
They call me Brian rockhold calendar.
Call me Brian the front.
You don't want to stage.
Well,
they do that now
when we do the live shows,
but then it goes,
let's see,
kick.
Oh God.
My wheel kick case say I need to do is
get you some of these barbell jeans.
He could throw up two kicks with Tom.
Obsessed with those please.
This is the shit man.
Apparently a diesel diesel makes them
too.
We get to deal.
I need something I have a beautiful
backside get ahold of.
I'm sure they follow you.
All right.
Get Ahold of me.
Lazy.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
And these chairs can always just order
them these chairs and let's get some
barbells.
Ergo depot.
Let me,
let me see what you were called.
Pisco.
The genes.
Stand out.
Let me see how tight they are.
I know they're not.
They're not.
They're tight.
Dickerson Rogan has a thing.
I know he does.
That's not bad,
dude.
They're like sweat pants.
Look like that,
bro.
You're basically wearing joggers,
dude.
You're like Addison's job with those
knees.
Like no judges,
no binding.
Ridiculously flexible.
Like you really,
it's so stupid.
You show off in Yoga.
No,
just do yoga.
There's girls in my class that are a
hundred times more flexible than me.
This is one Indian chick and my yoga
class.
He does that.
A bow pose where she gets her foot
literally up in the air like way above
her head.
Crazy.
It's insane.
It's crazy like that.
I silly.
I just sit there like this.
You get competitive.
I don't get comparing.
I don't want to blow my asshole out.
So I just said,
how often you've been doing this yoga.
Three times a week.
That's awesome dude.
It's so good for your body,
right,
that man.
Do you feel like your body,
like your back's loosening up and loosen
on everything?
For me it's more of a mental thing.
It's just feel great after I do it.
Me Too.
More compassionate,
relaxed.
I'm bored.
I don't want to say I'm bored with
Jujitsu,
but it's,
it's all the same to me.
You know,
like I'm going to the same guy so I
wasn't feeling like,
why don't you move around,
go to a different job.
But you go in gear.
I'll know gay.
Uh,
just depends.
I'll do both.
I'll do both a lot.
A lot of Gnocchi,
but I'll do both.
Just have you thought about doing
Jujitsu competitions?
Do you let them know we're not finding
the time to put the proper training into
it and just because of doing the podcast
or to have a kid?
Everything lot going on.
Podcast shows everything,
man.
It takes,
it takes a lot of time.
He does dark and dicing and everything
and I wouldn't want to do myself a
disservice by showing up half ass.
Like,
I would never do that.
So I can be 100% that there's no way I'd
sign up for one.
What if like Metamorris came at you or
one of those other organizations?
It's like Ebi,
I would help if Eddie approached me and
we talked about it at the right timing.
I do it.
I don't know if I'd do metamorris again,
just cause personal issues,
but with,
with,
with Eddie,
if like some super fight type deal.
I love Eddie.
If you,
if he said,
hey,
I want you to do super fight here and it
was the right time,
I'd do it.
What'd you fight me?
What'd you fight?
Cyborg again.
Now when I say Cyborg for folks
listening,
we're not talking about Christina.
Is it Chris?
Christine,
Christina.
CYBORG females.
Yeah.
We used to be Santos and Justino I think
it is.
I think you're right.
Um,
she's uh,
uh,
invicta women's 145 pound champion.
We're talking about,
uh,
Ricardo,
Ricardo Abreu,
who's also known as Cyborg and not to be
confused with Cyborg evangelists.
He's also the number one grappling in
the world.
Yes.
Well,
he's very high.
Is there a number one guy,
number one,
because he beat booze Shesha last year I
think in Abu Dhabi.
So he technically he was an absolute,
he's a fucking monster fucking monster
and this tornado guard,
goddammit man,
you watch that guy's fucking,
he's,
he's amazing.
He's amazing.
And his strength and conditioning videos
are also super inspirational.
The crazy shit that he does that cause
I'm a fan man and,
and you know what else I like about him?
He's like a crazy world traveler.
He goes all around the world that goes
on travel,
so see the world and I follow him on
instagram.
It's really cool.
Yeah.
Like he's like dude talking about
wanderlust.
Like he loves like going,
he was in South Africa,
he goes to Africa,
he goes all these different places like
every couple months is instagram is him
and some new country like having a good
time doing Jujitsu.
Like he did.
He does.
He posts pictures of his girl on this.
Graham,
I don't know her ass.
You could sit this fucking coke.
Rarely she walked by,
I was like,
God damn,
you might've got a shop shut down.
But you when my man here,
girl is reading,
he's a big handsome so's yours by the
way.
Both you guys shut them down there too.
It's a double shot shot shot.
Look at that.
Oh Shit.
Neutralize
shop out loud.
That would be fascinating.
Notice he guys under that rule set to
that Ebi rule set is dope.
I love the fucking what we're talking
about.
Eddie Bravo put together this
invitational tournament that Brendan and
I went to yesterday and Joey Diaz and
um,
it was fucking sensational.
Best I've ever seen.
So goody this morning I said,
Bro,
I been a lot of Jews to competitions.
I've been in,
you know,
high level in myself.
I've never seen anything like that from
start to beginning.
You're like,
Oh shit,
this is what that's great about it.
It cuts out all of the,
like there's no,
no one's going to be in danger.
It's going to be,
you know,
like a total stalemate.
Even if it's a total stalemate,
which some of them were at the end of 10
minutes.
You go into positions like you remember
in wrestling how you'd start off,
uh,
behind someone will in this Eddie,
we'll start you off.
You have a choice of one or two options.
You can take.
Spider web.
Spider web means someone's defending the
arm bar,
but you have both legs locked on them,
on the ground there.
They're on their back flat.
You're inside control with one arm
hooked and you are,
you're holding onto the leg.
That's how you're allowed to start.
Ready,
set,
go.
Can you start from there?
Or the other position is you take the
back,
both hooks in,
over,
under,
not under the Chin but over under it
like this and they're allowed to hold
on.
They're defending the,
they hold on your hand,
ready,
set,
go.
And then it's a battle for their,
so everyone's in fucking danger.
Yeah,
everyone's in danger.
It's really similar to college football
overtime where they built,
you're both in a dangerous position.
Whoever scores first.
And then the cool thing is,
is whoever got out fastest at the end
and she wants,
so if there's no,
there's no submission.
So they'll do like three rounds of it.
Is it three rounds?
So you bounce back and forth.
One you want,
you go,
there you go.
He gets his manager or whoever taps the
person first gets it.
But if you go and you tap him,
he has an opportunity to tap you next
cause he gets position.
It's incredible.
It's so good.
So there is,
we're at the orpheum,
it's sold out.
There's thousands of people.
They're fucking Jujitsu fans and they're
going crazy.
We had so much fun.
Wow.
It was so good for Eddie.
Bravo is killing it.
He's fucking killing it.
It's you.
Any problems?
Got 50 fucking schools.
Okay.
I think more now I'm saying 50 that's
the last count I know of.
I think he opened up a couple more of
them all across the country has got
affiliates in other countries.
How about an eggshell?
Yeah.
Amazing.
$50,000 grand prize.
He's going to be a mogul for grappling
for grappling.
50 grand.
It's about if such a geek is about doing
what you do really well and focusing
just on that though,
it look like I'm loving it and he's got
the best personality ever.
He's just such a character and he's,
he's joking around while he's like
referees saying funny things while he's
referencing but not trying.
Right.
You know,
like something happened and he jokes
around about it.
It was great.
We enjoyed the fuck out of it.
Yeah.
It's just so nice to see someone figured
out a way to make grappling really
excited was planning to leave early.
I'm like in an idea and it was,
I was like,
what?
Like can I get a little depressed?
But that,
you know,
cause usually just who takes forever and
it's like kind of boring.
Yeah.
Shit was railing well,
I wasn't going to miss it for the world.
In fact,
I,
I flew in from Vegas,
I got up at five in the morning.
I went from Vegas,
I took the airplane to La,
drove to Disney land,
hung out with my family till four
o'clock.
God in my car.
Drove to Eddie's thing,
went from five to eight 30 at Eddie's
fucking nuts,
man.
You know how you,
I think on the Whitney Cummings
podcasts,
you said you look at Kevin Hart and he
makes you feel lazy so you want to work
harder.
Yeah.
I think you mentioned something like
that.
That's how you,
what,
this is what you do for me,
like I was talking about it with someone
the other day.
I was,
I'm sorry to me about it.
Let's do,
yeah,
I'm like,
dude,
what don the podcast yet,
because sometimes on a,
I'm,
I'm still in my,
uh,
fighter kind of mindset where it's like,
okay,
Monday through Friday,
do work Saturday takeoff Sunday,
take completely off and then reset on
Monday and then Wednesdays light days.
So,
you know,
I'm kind of used to that,
but there's none of that in this world.
I'm in now.
Scheduling,
we're doing that web series,
not when we're doing coming up with
ideas,
but all of this man.
And then I touch you.
I'm like,
dude,
you're fucking nuts.
I can't believe you do that.
And you texted me,
he said,
I don't waste time.
I screenshot that.
You're like,
I don't fucking waste time.
Like he's fucking,
somebody wanted your number.
Who was,
you know,
um,
and uh,
you were like,
you know what?
I don't have time for people like that.
I don't,
I don't want to deal with that with
their dues.
Yeah.
I,
there's,
there's I a lot of things and what I've
found that the best way to live my life
from me,
I'm not saying you know,
other people,
some people really love their life to
sit around and fuck off.
When I sit around and fuck off,
I don't like me.
I like to get things done.
But the things that I do,
the recreational,
they're all fun.
Like Disneyland was fun as fuck with my
kids.
Um,
Eddie Bravo,
the invitation was fun as fuck.
The UFC was fun as fuck my show sold
out.
Show at the coffee it or where they do
the Cirque de Solei at mgm with Joey
Diaz and Jim Norton.
Friday night fon is fuck the fuck is fun
as fuck too.
Those are jobs.
Right?
But those are fun things.
Yeah.
And you know,
training,
training is fun.
Standup comedy couldn't be any fun.
Or you know,
the only real work work is like got to
discipline myself to sometimes work out
when I don't want to write when I don't
want to,
but,
but I,
this is,
this is how I feel is harder for me to
not do what I'm supposed to do then it
is for me to do what I'm supposed to do.
Because if I don't do what I'm supposed
to do,
then I deal with regret and doubt.
I don't,
I've done it before.
I've done it a lot of when my life,
I've felt those feelings,
I don't like it.
So what I do is I just don't do that.
I just say,
well what is the difference?
If I don't do it,
then I'm gonna have to feel like I
didn't do it and feel like a loser.
So get after it bitch.
I think it's good for just for people to
hear it,
to know your schedule cause you're at
where you're at.
You know what I'm saying?
Because your work ethic.
So,
so for me,
like if I look at someone,
it's like,
God,
how'd they get there?
Fuck man.
And the schedule is insane.
It's very rare that someone is
successful that doesn't have a crazy
schedule.
And if they are,
they're not going to appreciate it.
They're gonna you know like,
but it's,
it's all like what you,
what is where you're at.
Like is where you're at,
where you want to be.
Like are you enjoying it?
Because I'm,
what I'm happy about the most is that I
enjoy what I do.
So when I'm doing,
like if I was working as a ceo of some
fucking corporation or something like
that and I was putting all these crazy
hours,
like the same kind of hours,
I put it now the same kind of effort,
I'd probably be a miserable drunk pill
popping psychopath who's just looking to
escape and go bang hookers or something.
I'd be looking for some sort of a
release.
You know why you're doing it.
Like I think you got to get back to the
why sometimes lose motivation.
You've got it.
You've got to go back to the why.
What are you really trying to do?
You know,
it's,
it's like with standup,
I was thinking about this this weekend a
lot and,
and you get to a point in stand up and
you know,
this is making a lot of people laugh for
an hour is not really,
a lot of people can do that.
Are you,
are you growing?
Are you writing new stuff?
Are you being thematic?
Are you surprising yourself?
Are you coming up with a whole new
angle,
a new idea?
Or are you falling back on your old
tricks?
Even if it's a variation on that theme
and that that challenge never goes away.
Yeah.
There's that feeling when you don't do a
new joke because you like,
you're scared of it.
It's not going so well.
So you go back to some old stuff,
you know works and it gets a lot of
pills,
but you feel hollow,
feel dead inside and you feel hollow.
Well you can't,
can't fake yourself.
You can't trick yourself.
No.
The guys who can or monsters look
terribly,
don't
I feel inauthentic.
And also when you just send them,
you have people coming back to see you
three times or whatever you owe it to
them.
I can't come up with the same bag of
tricks and it's really hard to write new
material.
It's really hard to have a new hour and
be thematic after a year.
It's really,
really difficult.
But part of me dies when I go back
sometimes in my [inaudible] old faithful
just to get that laugh just,
and you also have to be entertaining
you.
One of the things I said talk to Jim
Jefferies about this.
I'm like,
when you do nudge him,
Jeffrey's Ya Jim Gaffigan.
I like when you do a new specialty,
abandoned all your own material.
He goes,
yeah,
a lot of it.
But he goes,
it's important for me to do news top,
but it's also important for me to do
well.
It's like people pay a lot of money to
come see me.
I have to make sure the show is really
good and sometimes I get people shout
out,
they liked some of the old stuff.
They want to see the old,
the new,
the old songs.
So you'll give it to him and stuff.
But with Jeffrey says,
or excuse me,
cafe,
and I keep doing that.
Gaffigan has that,
would that hotpockets thing,
it's almost like can't,
can't do stand up without doing that hot
pocket.
Yeah.
And sometimes Louis C k they'll yell out
the bag of Dicks.
That bag of dicks choke.
Yeah.
Man,
you missed some of those old beats and
those old songs,
but you,
I think if you're not constantly a
little bit uncomfortable,
this is gonna sound weird,
but I was thinking about this.
I go and spar with Chris mannered and he
doesn't beat me up.
He doesn't hit me.
I mean,
it'll hit me,
but I say,
just don't break my job.
Don't please don't hit me in the nose.
But I'm nervous.
I'm always nervous.
I don't want to go spark.
I don't want to do it.
I'm nervous and we move around and we'll
go four rounds.
I'm exhausted.
I looked like shit.
I get hit.
I,
I'm,
I don't feel good.
But when I do that and I feel
uncomfortable and I sit in my car and
I'm all sweaty and um,
and you know,
I,
I did a bad job,
but I overcame that fear on a Saturday
and I went and did it anyway.
Something happens where I get more
creative where I just start writing.
I don't know what it is,
but it opens up a different camera.
It's brain trauma.
Maybe it's also a lack of regret because
you don't have the regret that you
didn't,
you didn't shy away from something that
was challenging.
Instead,
you embraced it and then you get
excited.
The fact that he did it.
Yeah,
I did it,
and being excited about things also is
like creative fuel.
I think it's so important to do that.
I'm not finding that physically.
I get it mentally from all the shows and
our merchandise and doing all this in
the podcast,
but as far as physically plus class,
but you're getting it a little bit out
of 'em.
I just realized that's a fighter and the
kid tee shirt,
that metallica shirt,
that's our west coast.
I can't wait for scrooge mcduck.
There will be a scrooge mcduck slider
when the kid's shirt.
I will be wearing it on this podcast.
It will be limited edition because
warner brothers,
we'll find out about it and it will be a
problem.
Let it sit on.
The darkness is going to have to sell
only with bitcoin so nobody could get
money out of it.
Hooks to,
Oh,
I didn't get the money for those.
I got to,
we're out of here.
I got around four 30.
Come see me in that at the Atlanta
Improv this weekend.
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
It's a great room.
I love Atlanta.
I'm doing the tabernacle there.
Um,
I in January,
I think sold out.
You,
sorry.
You do theaters firing the kid lives
fighting a kid live.
Good.
How are we doing what we do?
We've got Seattle.
How are we doing?
Seattle,
Portland,
Vegas,
San Diego.
Everyone else sold out.
Fighter and the kid live.com.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Nope.
It's just tea fat k.com.
[inaudible] Improv this weekend.
[inaudible]K and I'm at the Bob Carr
Theater in Orlando on Friday night.
All right.
See you later.
You're fucked.